in what may be one of the strangest
articles i have ever seen in relation to
the culture war the week is asking why
republicans are so concerned about
grooming and i don't i think maybe
they're trying to make a semantic
argument like why why are republicans
concerned about this greater concept but
it shows the naivete ignorance or
devious nature that is behind the
defense of the parental rights and i'm
sorry the defense or the protests
against i should say the parental rights
and education bill there's a reason why
republicans don't like grooming uh
because they like their kids you know
they love their children and they don't
want predators coming after them and now
we have all of these articles coming out
from the left from establishment media
defending
what is
defending these ridiculous ideas uh like
having adults have secret conversations
with children about sexual things
and it's it's just really strange how
they're
they have no choice i suppose but to
come out overtly in support of these
ideas because
they falsely smeared the bill they need
this kind of
they need teachers to have the ability
to separate children from their parents
for their ideology but it puts them in a
serious bind when the subject matter is
hey don't groom which means parents have
a right to know and now they're forced
to defend this bill i i think
republicans have uh principally gone
after the issue i don't believe there
was an ulterior motive i don't believe
there's a secret definition of what
grooming means unlike the left that
redefined white supremacy fascism and
racism for the most part republicans
legitimately mean grooming when they say
anti-grooming but of course the left
likes to redefine language this may be
one of the most successful culture war
campaigns because regular parents
understand what's happening to their
kids which is why we saw this
election in virginia we saw a loudoun
county scandal we see a republican win
because these parents don't like what's
happening in these schools to their
children and they don't want it kept a
secret from them that's what's happening
so we have a whole bunch of articles
about this because now we've got texas
making a big push for printer whites and
education i'm hearing people mention
louisiana we've got ohio doing the same
thing we'll talk about that we've also
got a very funny story we'll talk about
more outrage over elon musk over at
twitter
there is something going on in
california with a bill that would
prevent prosecution
criminal or civil penalties against a
person a person if
something happens that results in a
perinatal death so what pro-lifers are
saying is california's basically
legalizing post-birth abortion
now there there was an amendment made to
the bill so we'll break down what's
really happening and it is it is kind of
alarming what they're proposing it's not
nearly it's not the worst case scenario
many people on the right are saying but
it is still really bad so we'll get into
all that plus we got polls coming in
democrats it's looking really really bad
even chris hayes is issuing a dire
warning about what we can expect in the
november midterms
yeah yeah the polls are so good they're
preparing for russian interference
that's right that's right joining us
today is uh will chamberlain
good to be with you uh senior council at
the internet accountability project in
the article three project and always
happy to be here right on yeah great to
have you man james is here seamus
coughlin of freedom tunes we upload new
political cartoons every week we're
uploading one tomorrow so go over there
and subscribe you'll enjoy it ian
crossland the favorite devil's advocate
i was gonna try and take a devil's
advocate position on this grooming thing
because i have a feeling people in this
room kind of are in agreement about how
cruel and insane it might be but i don't
think i can it seems too so too soviet
to me to get it to get them it's like
how can i support what they're saying
how can i understand not this time
no understanding their mentality is the
first step but uh let's go there well i
am very concerned about their mentality
i don't think they're coming from a
place good faith so we'll read some of
those articles and see what they're up
to yes but before we get started head
over my friends to timcast.com and
become a member to help support our
journalists and the hard work they do
every day we're a member supported
website so all of our journals are
employed thanks to you guys and you'll
also get access to exclusive episodes of
the tim cast irl podcast we will have
one up for you tonight at 11 p.m and
that's over at timcast.com but don't
forget to smash that like button right
now subscribe to this channel if you
have not already and share the link to
this show wherever you can if you want
to help support the show that grassroots
marketing is tremendously powerful it's
something these big networks don't have
you ever notice the new york times with
their 10 or whatever million followers
on twitter can't get retweets it's
because they have no support people just
know who they are let's change that up
share the show if you want to help out
let's jump into this first story
behold one of the most absurd articles
you will ever see from the week why are
republicans so concerned about grooming
i just want i just want to pause real
quick what a great question
this headline
should make it clear to any and everyone
that there are two distinct universes
that exist in terms of morality
there is no conservative post-liberal
libertarian civil libertarian whatever
who would question why grooming is bad
but apparently to the establishment left
to the corporate left democrat whatever
and many leftists who would defend this
they're outright just like why are you
mad about your kids being groomed
yeah
yeah the morality is just it's just sep
it's it's parallel realities the most
the most charitable possible
interpretation you can give to this
article is that he's essentially saying
that this grooming isn't happening and
it's moral hysteria right that seems to
be what he delineates in this article so
yeah here's the question why would
republicans be concerned about grooming
is it the case that florida tried to
pass or did pass a parental rights and
education bill that said you can't talk
to 48 year olds about sexuality then
tell them don't tell your parents after
you have a conversation with them about
sexuality and perverted ideas and then
the entire media said that that was
wrong and we should oppose it i think oh
wait it is so it's perfectly reasonable
but let's make sure we we we preface
this with
there was a bill that was passed in
florida
there it says classroom instruction on
orientation and identity is prohibited
kindergarten through third grade or in a
manner that is not age appropriate it
further clarifies that in any instance
of treatment given to a child for mental
medical or physical reasons the parents
must be informed and the school and its
employees can't encourage children to
withhold information and must provide
information to parents on certain issues
the parents have a right to sue how now
when that happened what did the
establishment media come out and say
yo why do you hate gay people yep and i
was like whoa whoa wait hold on hold on
a minute you know we're like hey we
don't we don't like you know creepo's
coming after our kids and they're like
you hate gay people it's like
that that association happened in your
mind yes
yeah like this is it reminds me you know
the kevin spacey thing when he was you
know accused of uh of pedophilia and he
was like let me admit i am a gay man
like what
that's right very bold right very bold
so this is i think you know they tried
what actually was extremely reckless uh
rhetorical gambit right same for spacey
though it was just assaulting dudes i
don't think they were kids i think i
think they were like teenagers
were they were those were they underage
i'm pretty sure yeah that there was some
reports of him trying to like seduce
underage males oh yeah yeah oh that's
the case yeah so uh that would that was
why it was like i'm going to admit i'm a
gay man was such a joke right yeah like
everyone's like did you do it and he
goes i'm gay
[Laughter]
okay not responsive bro don't know what
has to do so yeah right so so here's
what i would say about this article
i i'm i'm not uh uh interested in
trying to give the benefit of the doubt
to people who would call all of us
fascists or nazis or white supremacists
so when they read an article that says
why are publicans so concerned about
grooming
do they not realize what they're saying
with that headline to the average person
yeah does the average person understand
they're talking about a semantic debate
and i'm not going to go ahead and assume
that he actually writes in the article
that it's hard to know how much of this
is sincere hysteria and how much is ugly
mccarthyist politics or uh how about
this dude is so out of touch the left is
so in favor of grooming they can't see
it as grooming or being bad that's what
i'm saying i think this spawns from uh
guidance counseling in high school went
out to high school it was like if you're
getting abused at home you can come talk
to the guidance counselor and the guy in
confidentiality they'll report it to the
police for you kind of thing so like
your parents aren't going to destroy you
for and that's why i think this
mentality is like if you think you're
trans and you're six then they're that
we don't want then it's abusive for your
parent to tell you it's not mentality
and so they're trying to do this behind
the parent's back because they don't
want the kids yeah but suffer abuse but
it's not it's not the same thing it's
not abuse look these parents are going
to be with these children for 79 years
well probably the parents will die
before then but let's just say average
life expectancy 55 years average you
know 55 to 60 years the parents will be
with their children their entire lives
how about that the teachers one year
one year so how about if a five to nine
year old says something the teacher says
maybe this is something that's best
suited for your parents to figure out
with you because they're gonna be with
you for the next decade then you know as
you go through these issues in school
your parents will be a constant for the
entirety of their your school career or
whatever we'll only be one year out of
the whole the entire time and the kid
goes but i'm afraid to tell my parents
and then so it spawns from that and it's
like well they're afraid we can't make
them do something and the teacher should
say you should never be scared of your
parents a good teacher would do that but
if parents are beating their kids then
they should say we're going to call you
know child services right a good faith
exception sort of ends up swallowing
like the normal behavior right and again
like the arrogance here of these
teachers to be like well no i should be
able to talk about you know instruct
these kids on sexual orientation and i
should be able to have secret
conversations about their gender
identity like no no no no this is not
your child there's a parent and i think
it's not a surprise that all these
people are like single or or childless
why are
i i gotta i gotta go at this semantic
argument real quick obviously people are
gonna argue on the left that the the
article is not suggesting that they
don't understand why grooming is bad
they talk about all that stuff in there
the the article itself is trying to
separate what grooming means
into something else yes that's why it's
in quotes what they're trying to do is
when when when uh it's again i hate
saying conservatives trying to redefine
it you're right already they're trying
to redefine what the word means when we
see photos of there's that photo of that
little boy with the adult naked man you
remember that one yeah and and it's like
a drag show and the left was like this
is fine and i'm like the dude is buck
naked or there's the the desmond kid who
is stripping on stage but that's just a
dredge i'm like no it's not if anyone
who's ever been to across this country
and knows what strip clubs are like
there are fully clothed strip clubs
where the wind can't get naked there are
topless bars and there are fully nude
bars that means strip clubs actually
have exist where the women just take off
their clothes to their under layers
which is exactly what that little boy
was doing they are doing child stripping
and they're like how's that grooming
when when conservatives post-liberals
whatever this faction is says we don't
want teachers having conversations about
sexual concepts to children it's just
that because you because this is what is
being what they're pushing for when they
then come and say what could they
possibly mean by grooming yeah so yeah
no they're lying it's interesting they
kind of answer their own question here
and i want to make another point first
on this whole uh point about not being
sure how much a sincere hysteria and how
much is ugly mccarthy's politics that's
rich coming from a member of the party
which spent years calling us russian
agents for disagreeing with them but
they still then they still do so in this
article he says
that this is dishonest because most
americans will hear the term referring
to groomer and understand it to mean
something much more violent than quote
encouraging kids to question their
sexuality in the church unquote here's
the thing if you ask most americans
how they would label an adult
encouraging a child to question their
sexuality and then telling their child
not to speak to their parent about the
conversation they would label that
grooming it is a completely fair term in
fact it is the most accurate possible
term to use in that situation never you
ever watch uh law and order svu yes
justice system that's right and there
are many episodes where there'll be like
a child victim and they'll be like did
anyone tell you not to talk to your
parents did anyone tell you you won't
get in trouble if you tell us because
groomers go to kids and say don't tell
your parents i told you yeah if there's
a 16 year old that comes up to your kid
on the sidewalk and tells them
you'd probably see people go irate but
if it's a teacher now all of a sudden
there is an argument that it's okay if
it's a teacher doing it and not a 16
year old neighborhood bully like weirdo
coming up and doing it on the street
what's the freaking difference man like
stay mad you know again right you know
the fact that there's conservatives who
finally we have like this rhetorically
very potent like description grooming
and yeah i mean i do think it creates
there's a connotation to the extent this
article is correct i think there is a
connotation of like sexual predation in
it but that's not the only that narrow
definition is not the only thing that
grooming means that it you know
encompasses the idea of crimping is you
start slow that's the point but the
issue with this bill in florida is that
when it's it's literal grooming it's not
conspiracy and and what they're trying
to do now is this guy even says you know
it's q anon and then they try saying
like oh here we go the republicans are
all q anon and it's like why and they're
like republicans are accusing democrats
of being pedophiles and it's like
when um well hold on there a minute when
someone comes out and is like uh i would
prefer it if the teachers didn't have
conversations with children about sexual
issues and then tell them to keep it a
secret and they go yo why do you hate
gay people i'm just like first of all
what and why are you why are you
defending that
yeah
in the literal definition
you know what it's just very very simple
the left redefines words and what
they're trying to do right here is
they're trying to take the word grooming
which is what is happening and they're
trying to take this one piece and move
it out and move the goal post a little
bit like oh no no this isn't really
grooming republicans are lying because
technically if someone's having secret
sexual conversations with children that
doesn't count because we're talking
about lgbtqia stuff i mean this is but
this is something they always do right
when it's an epithet that applies to
their ideological adversaries we're
going to broaden the definitions so that
it encompasses their behavior when it's
a definition that applies to our
ideological allies we're going to narrow
the definition so it doesn't apply i
mean racism is the classic example like
the redefinition of racism is first
structural so it encompasses everything
in society but then prejudice plus power
narrowing it so that when our
ideological allies do things that are
overtly racist it actually no longer
becomes racist applies to them right
like it's just it's just lane it's just
word games right and so you know and all
of a sudden they're mad that republicans
have a word that is just a getting
traction like and then the worst thing
we have washington general type
republicans like you know i don't even
would call david a french republican
in general right um but saying like oh
no we shouldn't use this word it's like
no this is a very it's an one it's
effective and two it's perfectly
justified you know the funniest thing
was uh shout out to robbie suave from uh
he's from reason right and he was he
said something like it's weird that
people are saying students should know
anything about their teachers lives
something like that that was it was that
yeah it was yeah i knew nothing about my
teachers lives but especially in those
ages the weirdest sophistry i've ever
heard like no one cares no one is
arguing students shouldn't know about
their teachers lives they're like you
know i don't i don't care if the kids
know that teacher has a boyfriend i care
if the teacher is like gather around
children and let me explain to you
classroom instruction on these issues
and you're five years old it's like i
don't know if you've seen recent sound
part but mr garrison has been talking
about his like gay relationship in the
third grade class like that's the reason
i mean he's always done that right yeah
like it's literally like but that's i
think that's ultimately what they're
trying to do south park or south park
yeah there's the remember remember the
episode where um mr garrison
uh uh he transitions he becomes a trans
woman
and then he goes on a date
and then he comes in he's any and
mrs garrison is all angry
because all men are pigs and then tells
them they have to do weekend book report
on the old man in the sea
and it was like the south park actually
made jokes about the idea that the
teacher would be yelling at the kids
about sexual personal issues and that
was supposed to be comical in that it's
not real life yeah i think a lot of kids
saw that and it just wrote code in their
brain that it was real that's the
problem with parody and if that cartoon
was not a cartoon was like a real life
show i think people can it's not the
children children tiny adults tiny kids
can't tell the difference between comedy
and okay well hold on you're talking
about something totally talking about
the kids that are now teachers were
watching that crap back in the day and
thinking it was writing in their brain
like bro this was this is normal this is
normal like 10 10 years ago yeah exactly
so they were like 10 but um
they're not 20 years
south
that scene wouldn't have flown it would
have been shut down by the aclu or
whoever would have went after him hard
but because it's a cartoon all of a
sudden you can do this grotesque comedy
and i will say one of the weirdest
things about south park is that like
they have overtly sexual situations
between 10 year olds on that show all
the time i always thought that was weird
but you know
i think that's for adults like it's it's
it's a show about kids for adults like
and the kids aren't necessarily
meant to be in childish situations
they're often in adult situations still
i i find that weird that
it's just a weird circumstance with with
the show but considering the show isn't
overtly about that i'm kind of like
whatever we got big mouth too
and it's like okay it's just a joke
because it's animated but it's still
training people when south park does one
joke about butters and cartmen and it's
supposed to be like shockingly grotesque
and offensive i'm like man they really
pushed the line on this one but the show
isn't overtly about this when big mouth
is literally a show about children
engaging in sexual activities i'm like
why would someone want to watch that you
made a great point that it's a show
about kids for adults that's very
important it's like an r-rated cartoon
yeah so is so is big mouth and big mouth
also is messed up
i mean there are some things that are so
depraved that they shouldn't be on top
have you ever seen big mouth no i cannot
understand why people are like
look i gotta tell you man like i was
saying early on the moral universes are
just
distinct yeah yeah
big mouth is basically a bunch of kids
going through puberty and there's the
puberty monster it's a male and a female
and they're always trying to encourage
them to do these things or whatever i've
seen a couple episodes because i went to
someone's house who was playing it and i
immediately was like yo this is like a
nasty show bro i don't want to see a
show
even if it's cartoon characters there's
like a 12 year old boy beating it in a
in a bathroom and like that's the joke
i'm like that's not a joke that's just
gross
where people want to watch that
hey hey man look maybe i'm a square
these days
that's disgusting i thought the same
thing when i saw that show look at
cuties i think there's a there's a trend
here with what what they're doing yeah
like and they defended that to the death
too they defended cuties like crazy yeah
well and for a little while on the left
they were calling us what pedophilia
hysteria and now we're seeing a little
bit of a resurgence of that and what
people are concerned about with the
response to this bill isn't that it was
just some small handful of particularly
perverted teachers who took issue with
it it's that the entire dominant media
culture came out against it and said oh
of course adults have the right to have
secret conversations about sexual
matters with children
that's sick
it's not a moral panic to say that
there's something deeply wrong with the
social fabric of this country and we
need to address it it feels like the
term groomer has sparked something in
people and i was telling lydia before it
feels like cold water is splashed on
these people's faces the way they're
reacting to it like they're shaken
they're afraid and they're like why is
this even like the guy's article that we
just read he wasn't saying that the the
the conservatives are wrong for saying
grooming he's like what's the big deal
about like he's genuinely asking the
question because he wants to figure it
out somebody super chatted us this they
said um why is everyone forgetting about
the gay men's chorus
will convert your children i was just
going to mention that and and and it's
like they said it was the group defended
itself calling the video tongue-in-cheek
humor but it's like yo you said we're
coming for your children you think we'll
corrupt your kids if our agenda goes
unchecked funny justice once you're
correct we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you'll barely notice it you can keep
them from disco warn about san francisco
make them wear pleated pants we don't
care we'll convert your children we'll
make them tolerant and fair and then
they say we'll convert your children
someone's got to teach them not to hate
we're coming for them we're coming for
your children we're coming for them
we're coming for your children and then
they like they do
and then people are like please don't
and they're like you hate gay people
yeah well or those examples of teachers
on tick tock going on about how they are
going to educate your child on being
non-binary and alternative sexual
lifestyles can you imagine if some
conservative group made this video but
about conversion therapy or something or
christian should be completely deleted
off the internet where are we where's
the christian version yeah yeah we're
going to teach your children values and
make them worship the lord and all that
stuff they'd freak out maybe they'd lose
their minds yeah no the reason they're
so upset is because we're over the
people are over the target they've like
accurately taken this sort of like
massive amount of like untoward behavior
by teachers by like adults of all kinds
right that should be in should not be
happening and they've labeled it with
something they branded it and it's now
it's it's a really really sticky brand
let's let me pull this story we have
from timcast.com ohio introduces
parental rights and education bill takes
aim at promotion of divisive concepts in
schools so this was just from the other
day and it's similar to what we're
seeing with florida then we have this
story from texas tribune
critics of texas push for a don't say
gay bill say acknowledging lgbtq people
isn't the same as teaching kids about
sex well hey i agree the only so the
issue here is uh that's not what what
the conservatives the right or you know
people who who were in favor of the
parental rights bill did they did that
they associated lgbtq with this bill
they said it's called don't say gay now
they're complaining that people think
they're linked
isn't that just funny it's like the the
point i've been making since the
beginning is that someone's like hey
don't talk to my kids about sex in
secret and they say you hate gay people
it's like
you created that connection and now
you're complaining about the connection
existing these people live in their own
ridiculous universe well and it's also
laughable too that they would think that
bringing that connection up or creating
it would deter people from opposing that
bill as if i'm supposed to say or
anyone's supposed to say who is a parent
you know i really don't want my child to
be groomed or have uncomfortable
conversations on sexuality on the other
hand it might hurt gay people's feelings
if we don't let that happen yeah the
extreme metaphor would be like if the
nazis put clown makeup on their face and
then did what they did you'd be like
well it's they're just joking because
they look like clowns like you can't
just say you're gay and then el devious
behavior is okay it doesn't matter what
your sexual or how you claim what you
identify as doesn't matter a bunch of
clansmen wearing clown makeup and being
like no no no it's not about racism it's
about clowns like yeah you just hate
clowns
we're not buying it dude
it's a weird position
but the left keeps doing it i wonder if
it's actually working at this point
because you look at the polls man people
are just not having it parents
support the parental rights and
education bill because when you read it
when you read the summary when you read
the simple language it all makes sense
it's so interesting to me that the first
thing they say when you say this is not
good and we don't want groomies that you
hate gay people because it seems to me
like based on the chorus that we just
you know talked about and i was thinking
about that earlier i was like they
literally told us flat out they're
coming for our children i feel like
they're telling on themselves when
they're like well you hate gay people
because then they're like we're joking
yeah we're just joking remember
loud lydia remember remember when those
dudes went around claiming that they
were nazis but then they were like yo
it's ironic
these people don't deserve the benefit
of the doubt okay
neither do the people who are claiming
to be ironic nazis either truth be told
yeah if you're gonna parody i mean i
think it should be it should say parody
on the thing before you load it up like
a twitter account you go to a profile it
says this is a parody account you can't
like have to sift through it to find out
after the fact was that a parody or not
even
a good person
i got i got i got
this good at parody so i want to know
what you think you have to accept the
satirical posts you make i know this
because i post ridiculous garbage all
the time i tweeted something like elon
musk is on the board the fashion i was
like what if he just lets all the
fascists and nazis back on twitter and
then i put a crying emoji yes i fully
understand that some people may see that
tweet and think it's real i don't care
because it's not that serious but if
somebody wants to come out make extreme
statements like we're coming for your
children or that they're nazis you
better expect people to believe you're
being honest about what that is people
are going to believe your jokes
they don't know who you are yeah so it's
a good question this this wheel convert
your children parody isn't a parody in
the proper sense because it's not as if
they're coming out and saying the
opposite of what they actually want to
do right so if i do a cartoon with a
character named republican man who comes
out and goes i'm going to put cigarettes
and happy meals and get everyone's
children addicted to smoking for
corporate profits or something
ridiculous that's a parody that's
satirical because that's not something i
as a conservative would actually be
pushing for i'm making fun of the way
left-wing people portray conservatives
but what they're doing here is they're
in some sense trying to poke fun or at
or delegitimize this idea that
conservatives will say gay people will
try to groom or convert their children
but they do so by saying oh no we will
convert your children but they try to
use flowery language to describe that
conversion so they say well can we will
groom them or convert them into being
more tolerant or better people or more
accepting people when those are really
all just synonyms for what republicans
are talking about in the first place
which is accepting sexual degeneracy or
engaging in it if if republicans
actually were putting some kind of
addicted chemic addictive chemical or
advocating for it in happy meals
then i think the the the the distinction
there works better like conservatives
clearly aren't in favor of addictive
chemicals in food for children separate
high fructose which is why that would be
satisfying well but you're talking about
something a bit more organized
yeah but then
so so the issue here is conservatives
are like i think you're secretly
grooming my children and then they make
a video saying they're doing it it's
like okay exactly
accusing exactly republicans okay i'm
the villain you think i am watch me be
villainous now like that's not a joke
like this is something the left does all
the time they will for years resist the
accusations thrown at them by the right
only to come out and accept the
accusation in a cheeky manner so they'll
go yeah no we are trying to convert your
kids
but because they're doing it in a quote
unquote self-worth way they see it as
clever or acceptable when they're just
telling us something that we already
knew like when biden said he was obama's
vice president a couple days ago like
obviously i think he just doesn't i
think he doesn't know he was just joking
right but that but he was the vice but
he's making a statement about it's kind
of fact like obama's way more likeable
and powerful than he is it's true well
maybe not on paper today but i i don't i
don't talk to you we see this in other
ways though too right you can't you
can't try to parody himself
people will look at these videos of
biden and then try and push them to the
most extreme interpretation i don't play
that game people are like look at this
video of biden being lost and i'm like
he was looking for someone specific like
he was supposed to bring someone up and
introduce him and he couldn't find him
and so when when biden's like i'm the
vice president everyone laughs i'm like
i don't care if he said that he was
making he used to be biting he used to
be obama's vice president now when he
says trinidad a shop with a pressure
batter calf care and next already i'm
like that should be mocked and
questioned for sure yeah my point is
that the left has a habit of denying
accusations that republicans throw at
them to come out and either pretend to
be cheeky or act as if they're bold by
acknowledging that it was true all along
even though they spent years denying it
so we see this with uh people like beta
or going yeah we're going to come after
your ar-15 yeah we're going to take your
guns or what was popular among the left
about five or six years ago which was
going yeah i'm a socialist i actually do
believe in that because for years and
years and years they've been denying it
but then at some point they come out and
they act like they're brave and bold and
original for acknowledging the
accusation that we have been throwing at
them for years right they've repeatedly
it turns out it turns out the slopes are
in fact slippery yes
that's that's the key thing to realize
right they would be like oh that you're
just that's a slippery slope fallacy
actually like we should be at a point
where slippery slope is a default
assumption that accurately describes
reality and then you have to prove that
actually no this is one every every
almost every single argument patriot act
it's like it's a slippery slope to this
ah you're overreacting and now that then
you get 10 years later that the the
indefinite detention provisions in the
nda do people really not think that in
10 years like
pedophilia will just be another sexual
orientation like in the in the world in
the world
you know you're right it'll be a matter
of continuing exactly it'll start
digitally on the medical all of the
people who come out and favor it too are
going to act as if they're either being
cheeky or being bold in this exact same
way we see this non-stop how long is it
before some lefty writes an article
about how actually the grooming that was
being discussed all along is in their
view morally legitimate and then act
like they're they're bold for saying so
when we knew the entire time that that's
how they felt i think in 10 years
this is the joke we've said the
republican party will be a bunch of you
know transgender communists and the left
will be metaverse
you know um
what's what's what's what's the hive
mind uh metaverse yeah we'll be trying
to hold the line on pedophilia bad in
ten years right we'll be fighting that
right that debate well republicans no i
right right but republicans are
gradually just giving in to whatever
left wants exactly well hopefully
hopefully this is this is how we stop it
right like true true like don't give up
the brand it's ignorance
because it is grooming it's like the
bills are simple they're simple yeah
it's it's not like what the left is
doing with these nefarious tactics it's
like conservatives are just like uh we
want to we want to make sure parents
know what's going on and they're losing
their mind
the downside is they're responding to
the actions and they're not looking far
enough ahead to see what's coming to
prevent it which is the metaverse
grooming in the metaverse digital
grooming then you try to get haptic
feedback machines where you can actually
feel things on your body uh haptically
that's
incredibly disturbing to think about a
five-year-old with a haptic feedback
suit being groomed by some old man
on the internet and like so think about
that you got to start thinking ahead
guys if you're making legislation and
preparing and protecting from this stuff
well ban the internet just get rid of it
all everyone can use telephones i think
well i think you're right that in order
to fight against this one of the things
we absolutely have to do is refer to
this as grooming we need to continue to
use the proper language to discuss and
summarize these things but on top of
that it isn't just enough to use the
word we have to treat it as if it
actually is grooming if someone says i
don't support the don't say gay law and
then you explain what the law actually
is to them and after looking into it
doing the research and learning what it
means they're still against it stop
associating with that person they're
okay with grooming children i know we
talk a lot on the right about how we
shouldn't disassociate with people
because we disagree with our politics
but this is not disagreeing on politics
this is one group of people saying it
should be okay to sexually confuse and
groom children those are not the kinds
of people you want to associate with or
have in your life it there has to be a
social cost that a person pays for
supporting grooming i i understand i
don't know if ostracization is the key i
don't know you might be right there dude
look that's what i've been saying
there's two distinct universes here the
left knows exactly what they're doing
imagine there's two battleships in the
ocean and one of them is firing the
missiles and they're just coming
straight at the other and saying it's
getting bombed and then on on that ship
they're like now slow down we don't want
to we don't want to fight with the other
guys it's like dude at a certain point
you just say hey why don't we leave yeah
sometimes the fight is picked with you
and you don't get to change exactly and
as we say socialists don't have kids
they have yours exactly and this entire
you know conservative commitment to
never hurting anybody's feelings or
always being open-minded and tolerant
towards other perspectives including the
most absurd far less left perspectives
imaginable it doesn't really work with a
lot of issues especially issues like
this people have to stand up against
this this isn't just some abstraction
they're actually coming after children i
am i am genuinely convinced in 10 years
the republican party is going to be a
bunch of lgbtqia
because i i sit down and argue with
conservatives about the ahmed arbory
case
because they actually come in here and
they're like i believe that was all
justified that the guy who filmed it is
going to prison for the rest of his life
and i'm like why would he go to prison
and they're like well because they did
it and i'm like bro
if if people on the right are still
sending their kids to college people
with a straight face come in here come
on this show and they're like yeah i'm
sending my kids to college and i'm like
do you watch the show you're about to be
on do you know what is happening in your
country why would you advocate for that
for your kids yeah they'll be fine
i guess that's the way everything goes
just tired of being parents for 18 years
and are looking forward to the break or
something yeah but the break is simple
hey you're 18. get a job move out but
get an apartment you got to go to
college to do that
but but this is the point when
when you when you have people on fox and
conservatives
saying
you know what i think it was so that
they didn't look racist with the kyle
rittenhouse thing they said well the
kyle rittenhouse thing proves that
justice is served and the almond arbory
thing proves that we all believe in true
justice no the right caved on the ahmed
arbory stuff because they don't want to
look racist because many republicans are
more worried about the opinion of the
new york times than their own
constituents
whatever else is you know they're
worried about with with big media yes
which is why conservatives do not stand
up for their own values and which is why
we are in a situation where if you are
in favor of the grooming bill there are
zero social consequences but if you're
against it you could potentially lose
your job depending upon who your
employer is depending on whether they're
offended by that perspective people are
too afraid to speak out against the
abuse of children because they don't
want to lose their job
that's insane and the last time i was in
the show i was talking about this and i
was very pessimistic but i want to say
this if you're an audience member who's
watching this i believe in you i think
you have the opportunity to speak out
against this stuff you should and i
think you're going to do it i think the
people watching the show are going to
get fed up with this stuff as fed up
with it as we are and they're going to
be bold about it i really hope you are
it was a couple years ago we were
talking about how you need to stand up
against the wokeness because they're
literally burning down cities people are
dying and we kept hearing people saying
yeah but i'll lose my job and i have
kids okay well now the issue has
escalated the point where they're
grooming your kids in these public
schools
and people are like but i'll lose my job
and it's like okay dude look
if you are okay with your kids being at
these schools where you know they're
grooming them because you don't want to
lose your job then i i don't think i
need to advocate for any of this stuff
to you because you're not interested in
actually making things better i
understand life's hard but the crazy
thing to me is that
people once got on a boat for three
months to come to a barren shoreline and
many of them died just because they were
like this i need a better life for my
kids and now people are like
i i don't know what i would do if i lost
my job well like sheamus said there
there's there's other jobs out there
there's there's a path forward but more
importantly i guess maybe it's easy for
me to say i don't have kids and that's
that's that's what everyone says but uh
i've asked this question of everybody
would you rather have a job
and know that your kids spend eight
hours a day with a groomer or be
homeless with your kid not knowing where
your food's coming from and everyone
always says homeless with my kid not
knowing where my food is coming from
yeah so that's it right yeah yeah i mean
it's like but you know this is why we
need laws right like because ultimately
you know people need to be able to work
like part of like what we're all trying
to build on the right i assume is a
world again where you can people can
sustain a family on a single income
people can
like not necessarily like not
necessarily have to do child care and i
think one of the basic the basic
functions of public education especially
you know those early ages where you're
talking like five to ten is
child care like that's a basic function
that the state is performing um so that
people can go off to work and not have
to stay home with their kids let's let's
just i want to mention one more thing
all right um so
i want to mention this because on last
show when we did talk about this i said
i was a little bit black build and i i
was saying that there are people who
really will will watch the show and
think about these ideas but they're too
afraid to talk about them and reading
the comments section it turns out there
are a lot of people who insist that they
are talking about these things in real
life and at their work and i just you
know i really want to commend them
because i know that's very difficult i
know it's very difficult to do and i
genuinely have faith in this audience
that if you're watching this and you
don't usually talk about this stuff you
have to and i really believe you can and
will it sends out shock waves when you
communicate concepts you see it
reverberating through our collective
consciousness we're going to we're going
to talk about republicans
how about this we have this tweet from
poster tubs who says spencer cox the
republican governor of utah is now
officially using the term latinx
in government documents you can't make
this up
and here you can see it says um it just
says le tinx
here's the best part take a look at this
from this is from stl tribune
conservative group shares misleading
video of utah governor spencer cox
listing his pronouns the zoom call was
part of a town hall with high school
students last spring
say in april 21 zoom call of spencer cox
republican listing his pronouns during
town hall for high school students has
spread on social media after a
conservative group shared an edited
version of it how is that misleading
it's literally him sharing his pronouns
they go on to say the original 30-minute
zoom call was part of the one utah
student town hall held last year where
utah high school students asked the
republican governor questions about the
state's kova 19 response the edited
video makes it appear the governor
listed his pronouns right after
introducing himself the statement is
followed by the added sound of a sad
trombone during the town hall one
student from tuacan high school for the
arts in irvin in irvines listed her
pronouns when called upon to ask the
governor a question
she then asked what his plans were to
boost mental health services in schools
citing a survey that found gay and
lesbian youth face a higher risk for
depression well thank you so much for
that question and my preferred pronouns
are he him so thank you for sharing
yours with me how is it misleading to
show that he literally did that he did
right because any like any real
republican would just be like okay and
then not list their pronouns right uh
misleading sorry again this is a new
redefinition misleading is something
that makes a progressive look bad
regardless of whether it's truthful
exactly right so like that used to be
i understand this actually has some
reasonable like heritage in english
common law it took a while before like
truth was a defense to libel claims
right like that was some yeah that was
actually alexander hamilton litigated
that case where he was the first or was
a lawyer who finally won the argument in
american courts that's like hey i guess
we have this first amendment now which
means that this idea that libel doesn't
that truth is not a defense to libel
that can't be right right so uh but that
you know it used to be i forget what the
exact exact term of it but but it's like
libel used to be just statements that
embarrass someone regardless of whether
or not they're true and you could sue
for that yeah you could sue for that
right before this before like before
really before the constitution even in
the united like colonial united states
got rid of that i hope people
effectively people could happen again we
could find ourselves in a medieval
situation where you get thrown in prison
for insult what someone else receives is
it that's crazy that's where we're going
shout out to alexander hamilton right
yeah hate speechless great guy people
people really you know i'm a big
hamilton guy as opposed to a jefferson
guy like hamilton actually like saw what
you know jefferson basically wanted us
to be an agrarian slave society
uh like you know i mean he didn't like
slavery that much but he wanted that and
hamilton was the guy who's like no
actually you know we should we should
have a a really powerful country
in general like america should be strong
well so going back to the main story
though this is just another very common
and typical erosion among republicans
who give in immediately because they're
spineless yeah no i mean i usually joke
that namely name a more useless
republican than mitt romney right who's
i love that tweet because everybody
engages with it and lists more useless
republicans
so um but yeah like utah what's going on
with utah guys like you're this is a red
red state and we have this whack a
whack-a-doodle liberal governor and a
whack-a-doodle rhino senator
yeah also get your stuff together
imagine
insulting yourself
on that level being a man
but telling people that you expect to be
referred to as he him as if they
wouldn't otherwise know what a
ridiculous cell phone
i i would if like i was in a situation
where for whatever reason they were like
you have to list your pronouns i would
absolutely just make up some really long
and ridiculous word and be like do it or
don't
fascinating thing about pronouns is it's
like
it comes out when you're not there right
how often do you're like oh he and like
they're not in the world it's like you
the only reason you use third person
pronouns is because you're not talking
to that person right right so it's like
you want to control how i think about
you when you're not here that's the
craziest thing which is you're right
you're actually doing violence against
me you don't think about me the way i
want to be thought of you know ezra
miller
the flash in the dc cinematic universe
or whatever or whatever it's called no
uh ezra miller came out as non-binary so
all the news articles say they them and
it's like you're butchering the english
language but it's not even that like
ezra miller as my understanding is not
trans
like just came out and said you have to
call me they them they're like okay
like
i understand
if there's an argument for a trans woman
who is overtly passing and
it was like what ben shapiro was saying
about blair it would be very difficult
or take a long time to explain why he'd
use a male pronoun for blair white in
public to his friends so he would just
say she her it's the easiest way to go
about things but in you know literary or
in in articles he would say he him and
i'm like i understand that point i
understand why it is simpler just to
refer to someone as she her if they're
overtly feminine or he him for a trans
man who's overly masculine like buck
angel for instance but when we're
talking about some you know some guy
who's like i'm non-binary but he's still
just a regular
you know young man
you can't just tell people i have to
refer to you in a certain way you don't
own that that you're you exist outside
of i i exist okay you exist over there
i've never seen you and yet i'm supposed
to refer to him by pronouns i never met
the guy well i don't know if you know
this tim but as it turns out you get to
define your identity without anyone
around you having to consent to it even
though by definition your identity is
how you fit into the group that you're
interacting with human society yeah it's
like the group that you're interacting
with has absolutely no say in how you're
perceived it's completely all up to you
and if they disagree with that they're
just mean until realism kicks in and the
ukrainian government's turning trans
women back that can't because they're
actually men and that are now trans
women are they converted uh we need that
we need the strong muscle on the front i
don't care how you identify yeah there's
always something interesting like
there's sometimes they the [ __ ] like
pro trans lobby if you will points to
certain societies say look there's an
example of of of you know how the
societies recognize trans people and
it's like the reason for that particular
society is because they're so homophobic
that the only way that you can dj is if
you transition in ukraine a
female to male transgender person
dressed up in women's clothing
and then crossed the border to escape
because i guess now
identifying as a woman she didn't want
to go to war
and because of hormone therapy presented
hormone therapy presented as male and
would get stopped at the border and then
sent to go fight i find that fascinating
then you have basically no matter what
the circumstances that you have trans
women and trans men just trying to
justify escape from the country in
whatever way they can the trans women
are like but i'm actually uh you know a
woman so i should be allowed to leave
but they're not letting me and the trans
man is like time to dress up like a
woman and same woman so i get i can get
out of here like if you want to be a man
that comes with the pros and the cons of
being a man conscription has always been
one of them but you know this is one of
the big things that uh we saw in the
turn of the century with suffrage
movement
the the women who opposed it were like
we don't want male responsibilities in
our lives which include i believe like
the fire brigade was one issue in some
areas
if you had been having the right to vote
meant that you'd you'd be called upon as
a man to fight the fire brigade and they
believed they could be drafted that was
something that they feared right
and they will be
yeah because maybe they will be next
time because if we have a draft if we
ever have a draft again people are just
going to identify as women to get out of
the draft it'll be a easy form of
and so you'll draft quickly have to
start drafting women too did you hear
about what's going on was it pasadena
where is it where they're going to be
giving um ubi to people who are
non-binary yeah yeah so this i was just
thinking about that and i was going to
bring it up
i think this is a brilliant bill for our
cause frankly because they're only
allocating about two hundred thousand
dollars to this program which means
they're going to run out very quickly
and it's impossible to define non-binary
because it's a non-existent meaningless
term so a bunch of people are going to
say they're non-binary to get the money
and it's going to run out extremely
quickly and people are going to see how
ridiculous it's just going to be another
demonstration of how nonsensical the
modern gender theory bs is
man i was my dad was a fireman growing
up and we when i went to the fire
department some of the early 90s i think
it was like 12 or 13 and there was a
woman that worked there and i was like
hey how come there's a girl that's a
fireman and he was like oh she because
women can be firemen too and i was like
well why wouldn't she be called a
firewoman he's like no they're all
called firemen and then when i went to
college it was like yeah we're all
actors men and women we're all
considered actors we don't use the word
actress it's ridiculous so i got it i
mean it doesn't really care matter what
you call it it's more about who you are
and i was like can you how did can she
carry the heavy equipment and he's like
no she works in the death at the desk
but i not that she couldn't carry the
heavy equipment she trained for it but
it was more about like less what you
call yourself and more what you actually
are that's what it comes down to when uh
when the crap hits the fan my friends
i've never really cared about you know
the words people use to describe me
it's the weirdest thing that people are
like you have to use someone's pronouns
or else but we're going to insult you
and call you names all day and night
like no no no you can't insult me i have
dictated the words you must use to
describe me that bill's successful
remember so anybody else yeah
that's the thing yeah it's violence and
abuse to misgender someone to not use
the proper pronouns but to try to have
secret conversations with children about
sexually depraved behaviors that's not
grooming right dude isn't it illegal in
canada to do that now bill
c-16 and then they passed another one
that jordan peterson was talking about i
didn't look into it yet but apparently
like if you misuse someone's pronouns it
can be a hate speech crime this is this
is insane
hopefully i'm not miscal if i'm
miscalculating this let me know in the
super chats or something yeah no there's
a there's some bill in canada that's
like dictating independent media or
whatever i think jordan peterson was
tweeting about it they want to control
what uh
reporters and people with large media
platforms can say
that's where it's all headed because you
saw what uh the seat the ceo of twitter
said years ago that we have to it's
about it's not about free speech it's
about how the times are changing and we
have to create a healthy conversation
and it's just like
these people are
definition megalomaniac sociopath
psychos all that stuff my worldview is
the only world view my world view is
moral and just and everyone must adhere
to the way i see things that is
psychotic behavior and sometimes the way
we see things they'll do that cult thing
where it's like me and a bunch of other
weirdos that have my same mentality so
we are stronger in numbers let me pull
up this story from timcast.com palm
springs testing guaranteed income
program for transgender and non-binary
residents the program is one of several
in california offering specific groups
of people with subsidized income so let
me get this straight if it comes to the
point where
trans people lgbtq people minorities are
getting subsidized income that just
basically means white people
pay taxes to subsidize all of the other
marginalized groups
that's the end result isn't it
i suppose it rallies everyone pays taxes
taxes but it only benefits one group
that doesn't sound right no they say uh
timcaster.com reports last month the
city council of paul springs voted
unanimously to allocate two hundred
thousand dollars to develop a guaranteed
income pilot program for transgender and
non-binary residents on march 24 the
city council agreed to pay dap health
and queer works to design the program
and apply for state funding
part of the three phases outlined in a
city report to bring the proposed
project to fruition california has
already made a statewide commitment to
provide 35 million in funding for
guaranteed income pilot programs like
other guaranteed income programs the
pulse palm springs pilot program would
provide direct cash payments to
individuals to spend as they see fit it
is set apart from some financial
assistance programs that come with work
requirements et cetera et cetera
i'll tell you what's going to happen
if you put this money up you're going to
have a whole lot of people being like oh
yeah i'm non-binary sure how much do i
make how much exactly self-government in
california has always been a huge
mistake or at least in the last 40 years
then who should govern it yeah right
like you know 180 years of statehood
enough i think it probably needs to
return to being a colonial territory
split in half do you agree with that
california benefit from being split in
half i mean it depends on how you split
it right like you you need to carve out
there there's a lot of red californians
right there's probably more
conservatives in california than any
other state because california is so
populated right right so there's
probably you know
60 40 democrat that's 8 million
republicans and we can use those
reinforcements in texas sure or any or
anywhere else in the country and in fact
that's what's happening with a lot of
them are moving i have so many so many
i'm from california originally i have so
many californian friends and
acquaintances who are moving you would
was a proposal that would take the uh
the western coastline which goes from
like san diego los angeles up to like uh
san francisco and then that would be its
own
state because the rest is red i wouldn't
do that i would want to make it half and
half if i could like split give san
francisco to the north to be the capital
make it half and half it's too blue
because you have all that farm it's two
watts it's two blue states right you
have to take both big montreal it's
already a blue state isn't it right
you're then you're creating two new
democratic seminars for no good reason
it's not even about that it's that
you're not solving any problems by doing
it i just don't see how like the los
angeles government can govern the
redwoods makes no sense that's why
look
if you cut the state in half you don't
solve any problems you still have the
democrats who agree with the democrats
whether the state is one or two states
you still have republicans in certain
areas being shut down and uh uh for the
two and the residents of tulare for
instance tulare county being oppressed
by the democrats in the big cities and
having their water taken away from them
so if you want to actually solve the
problems and restore people's rights we
tell all the people who live in these
big cities you got to be responsible for
yourself and work out legitimate
agreements for trade with the people who
live in these marginalized communities
but it's fascinating to me that they
come out and constantly say we must
protect the marginalized communities but
the entire structure of california
oppresses the the the uh eastern uh
desert areas southeastern areas and and
i cite two larry specifically because
the state takes their water away from
them dude takes away their surface water
the history of los angeles the the owens
river valley is this place in northern
california fascinating history so
william mulholland who they named drive
after went and he basically got them to
sign over their water rights in the
owens river valley so then he diverted
their river their water yeah l.a
shouldn't exist as it does no it doesn't
it's from outside water sources it
annihilated the lives of all these
farmers in the owens river valley and
then there was a giant flood the dam
broke and all these people died it's a
horrific story and that's that's the
beginning of los angeles as we know it
today probably just terrible it's got
beautiful mountains it's got it's got
lush greenery and redwoods california is
a gorgeous state pg e is running
all those wires
all those california fires man they're
coming from pete not all of them pg e
they're not taking care of their power
lines so they're they're falling down
and catching they spent a whole bunch of
months a whole bunch of money on
sustainability and not on like clearing
the lines around like this is not a hard
we've solved this technical problem for
decades it's like pg e just didn't spend
the money on clearing out uh you know
clearing out the forests around the
power lines i want to explain to
everybody how it's going to work under
this progressive utopia
in california i went and visited to
larry county to larry county how you
pronounce it i believe it's got 300 000
residents
they have no voting power
so these poor migrant workers all of a
sudden one day their water dried up in
their wells there was a drought and i
can understand that the farmers in this
county weren't allowed to take surface
water that they had a lot of i remember
driving past these canals full of water
and i asked the farmer like hey you got
water right there oh we can't touch that
and all the surface water goes right to
the cities because they just they just
take it from us
i'm like how is that protecting
marginalized communities that the
wealthy elites say we get all the water
and you guys go screw yourself we need
to protect the farmers yeah if we had an
electoral vote type system
representational voting in california
the way we do nationwide then tulare
county would have more power and that
would force the urban centers to
negotiate with them as to what they
actually give up instead the urban
centers say there's more of us than
there are views so we get your water
they're at the end of a dying uh nation
and not the united states no the these
these people think cities are the heart
of the country are wrong it's the farms
and you can now learn on the internet as
if you have a city you can get stuff
shipped to you our shipping is so with
drone shipping in the advance of drone
shipping farms are going to become even
more central the fact that bill gates is
buying up all this farmland is very
concerning to me like corporate farmland
we're gonna have to disperse that back
to the people at some point let's just
do it peacefully
let's bring it back to this story and i
just want to mention they are extracting
from the merit and they are giving to
the the unmerited
this this this ubi program and other
programs basically say if you produce we
will take and we will give it to people
for arbitrary reasons
i mean
is that not socialism
oh yeah that's that's pure socialism but
it's i mean it's going to be a well
miserable thing it's it's it's it's it's
precursor socialism i guess the prop is
the better way to say it it's like one
of the it's the seeds of socialism it's
the grooming process
so you have you have a farmer who farms
and he makes food and then eventually
they come in and they say we're taking
your farm away from you you elite and
we're giving it to all the people who
work here and all the people who work
here don't know how to farm and then
everyone starves to death
or worse still they're like everyone
melt down your your tools to make pig
iron and then everyone
starves to death i think that's been
done before yeah uh
by the soviets hey i got an idea believe
it or not what if we just did that what
if what can we find like a town and just
run someone as mayor and he can just
overtly run on failed socialist soviet
policy just to see how many people are
willing his name was bernie sanders
no but i mean like outright being like
we need to get everybody to melt down
their rakes
and their shovels this is the only
development in the world where we don't
belt down fuel does not melt steel beams
but but imagine going to like brunswick
maryland running for mayor and your
position is we should get everyone to
melt down their metal because we need
iron for the war effort
and then they're like what are you doing
it's like i'm just being a socialist
that's what you guys want right you're
socialists or actually i actually you
know we were talking about
if somebody actually did start running
for office in our area and i was like
why why why is that why is that funny
people were like hey we should get
someone that we know to run for mayor
wouldn't that be funny and i'm like
no it would be awesome because we should
be involved in politics and we should be
running for office yeah do you want to
do it well what move out here
no no
why aren't people being like i'm going
to run for mayor yeah that's what i want
to in i live in arlington
so like i would lose john when i moved
to north carolina
run as a democrat who opposes critical
race theory see how well you do right
yeah no one would go digging in my
twitter history
i couldn't delete my twitter wait a
minute that wasn't me
the john astor went to new york city and
then built astoria he built a city part
of the city and then just named it after
himself like that's the way that's
that's cool because then you know where
everything is and you have control of
like the the layout and stuff like that
you can do it right from there we should
you know we should do we should uh
we mentioned it before we'll make a
coffee shop
called the coffee beanie but then at 7
p.m every night the sign flips over and
says ian's palace and then all of like
the counters and everything spin around
and changes into an entirely different
building wouldn't that be cool we're on
the verge of like graphene pipes i don't
know if technology is good enough to
replace copper piping but copper rusts
and then you get copper oxide in your
water it's really bad for you and
yourself polyvinyl chloride man what do
you mean good old pvc bbc i'm lost
like we're gonna build
pipes if we're gonna build a city from
the ground up i want to avoid copper
piping
i don't know if it's really nasty i mean
in in cross landing or across land or
whatever
i love it what about like a denser uh
metal maybe something lead lead yeah
yeah yeah i think led's not a good idea
and then and then after we lay it we'll
complain to the government and we'll
talk about the poor children of of ian's
palace suffering and we got we need the
government to subsidize the replacement
of these pipes that we built what are
you gonna do what would you do at ian's
palace first night if i was hanging out
ian's palace it depends what kind of
establishment is this would i even be
there in the first place what kind of
seedy nonsense you got going on with it
you can't do it without you [ __ ] let me
know what's going on what are you eating
what's going on this place is going to
be g rated if i'm there i'm into it all
right perfect so what what what are we
serving what kind of whiskey well all
right
g-rated g-rated no no i'm not into the
psychedelic drugs caffeine
psychoactive drugs now that's right
those are people coffee ian's palace
you'd think it was like a lounge but
you'd go in there and it would be just a
bunch of like people who coming and
trying talking about graphics we're
trying to figure out how to how to map
inflation like uh if you if you can
redefine the uh the second what is it
the ideal gas law p equals pv equals nrt
pressure equals uh
volume times uh temperature you can then
add some sort of like expansionary uh
variable to that so that you can get
like right now when it when a system
inflates
is anyone listening to me right now i'm
listening
right now
it just goes out and in and that's the
ideal gas law explains how to like get
water out of a out of a system but it
doesn't explain fusion gesture you're
doing the heat that you're getting in
the system that causes it to expand is
causing it to expand faster which causes
more friction which causes more heat to
enter the system to expand faster and
then you get inflation which is why you
have fusion but people haven't
mathematically written that out yet and
someone out there is going to do it
well all right let's talk about politics
we have this uh we have this tweet from
chris hayes he says was just checking on
what happened in the 1946 midterms as
the nation readjusted after a historic
society why disruption and inflation was
eight percent don't google it so i
googled it yeah of course and we found
that uh the 1946 election resulted in
republicans picking up 55 seats to win
majority control well times they are a
changing it's very different these days
the parties represent very different
ideas but i think it is fair to say yeah
i mean maybe that much could you imagine
if we get blindsided by a republican
super majority in the house
how many how many seats would they need
to win for a super majority well there's
no there's no such thing as a house
super majority right like because it's
just fit it's 50 plus yeah right whoever
gets 50 percent plus one can vote it's a
senate super majority would be 60
i think or 61 no 60.
um and we could i don't think that's
even conceivable given the map so right
how many seats do you guys think the
republicans are going to need to pick up
to keep not doing anything
oh man probably all of them you know but
but hold on hear me out if the
republicans actually are in a cynic
let's be real let's be real if they're
able to pick up like 55 seats and just
change the shape of the house of the
house representatives then they'll
probably do nothing
yeah no well i mean
they're not going to be able to do
anything meaningful because biden's
going to veto it right we're still going
to have a democratic president until
they can impeach
that's what they can do they can do
investigations they should make the
january 7th committee and i actually
think that's
you know one better i have heard i've
heard whispers that kevin mccarthy is
actually going to like go hard on the
investigations and there's there's sort
of like the democrats have been have
pissed him off so much over the past
like two years that he's actually gonna
go like make them really pay for it a
bit i don't believe it i don't know
that's right here
if they make the mistake of making
mccarthy speaker of the house he's going
to be like i'm going to go after these
investigations and then he's going to be
standing tall in the moment they're like
and mccarthy has it he's going to go
and then he's just going to be like
armed tired yeah i don't know that's
more mcconnell i worry about it but who
knows who knows i mean it could be
i mean that's what they're gonna do like
i mean i know there's they're not gonna
i think there is definitely like a lot
of resistance like i heard matt gates
talking about this like there's a lot of
resistance into doing what the paul ryan
republican house did during obama which
was just pass a bunch of bills that they
knew never were going to go anywhere and
then find themselves
yeah subpoenas hunter biden
under oath lots and lots of subpoenas
you know get to the bottom of get to the
bottom of russiagate get at the bottom
of 100 biden testify under oath like
they made trump do yeah no just like
just embarrassing they would still call
it unprecedented sure sure here's what
here's what happens mccarthy primary the
guy
mcconnell whatever senate i don't care
who they are just get them out use
primary primary primary primaries across
the board get rid of everybody
bye-bye
i'm looking up ideally i'm trying to put
my mind in the heads of people in 1946
when they did this it was post-world war
ii so they're just getting out of this
traumatic world war uh harry truman was
truman republican german was a democrat
truman had not been elected right he was
a vice president
um and he
was uh you know when when franklin
roosevelt died right before the end of
world war ii he became president so
um
what caused all these what caused all
these people to get voted in was it it
might i mean just the end of the war
must have been such a paradigm i mean
a lot of the sitting leaders got thrown
out of office right winston churchill
got thrown out of austin can i just say
something real quick in england uh
don't the democrats claim the parties
switched in the late 50s yes they
claimed that during the civil rights era
the party switched so so how was him
after so if the party switched what
chris hayes is actually saying when he
says don't google it is that he believes
democrats are going to
yeah maybe they don't believe it i think
i think i don't know it's more that he
thinks that like the the party in power
is going to take a beating yeah right
right like basically this is this kind
of stuff people are people are not happy
and want something different and that i
mean that happened right winston
churchill literally is the guy who won
the war the guy who's the hero of
britain and he got tossed out in a
general election yeah like yeah they
hated him in the early days because
they're like all he talks about is war
and he's like i'm telling you the
germans are going to declare war he's
like ah that silly man and then finally
when the war broke out there we need
them now they brought them in when they
won the world like we don't need them
anymore yeah
war though man peace in our time huh
what a what what an amazing quote
that's neville chamberlain right right
yeah yes just yeah exactly wow um that's
why i wrote peace and prosperity because
they're not the same thing great book
that was a fascinating take on world war
ii from britain's perspective called the
phony victory by peter hitchens and his
basic thesis is britain was in effect
one of the losers of the war um that
britain prior to the war had some
pretensions of being a great power and
post-war they were a vassal of the
united states yep um and they better
know it and they basically like found
themselves in a war situation where they
were basically doomed their only hope
was the united states coming to save
them and oddly enough franklin roosevelt
and the united states
managed to extract major major
concessions from britain throughout that
period when they were in that really
difficult period in like 1940 um in
order to in for to be willing to help
the united kingdom what kind of we were
still not that happy about
bases oh they gave us their military
base gave us they had military bases in
like newfoundland and like in canada
and they just we just said that you want
our old destroyers like our old retro
you know not very useful destroyers give
us your land give us your military bases
whoa you know what that the king was it
a king at the time was it
yeah well they had i mean it was that
was also that was under chamberlain
right when they were starting to do i
think no that was probably under
churchill when they were doing len lease
i'm not sure i'm actually not sure who
was the reigning monarch at the time uh
king george so was george signing over
the land
no it would mean it
it wasn't up to him right it's at that
point it's still a constitutional
monarchy with technically prime minister
dominating the technically the king
could
yeah but it was still it was still at
that point where it's like the you know
the prime minister's running the
government of britain and so it was on
chamber neville chamberlain and
churchill to make the decision but i
mean they were just they were in a
terrible position i mean they could they
found a way to stop
a seaborn invasion by hitler's germany
but they had no hope i mean they got
kicked out of continental europe had to
flee from dunkirk and the miracle of
dunkirk was that they managed to
evacuate yeah you know most of their
forces
and i mean they had no hope of trying to
recall you know reconquer continental
europe
um
you know i mean and it's one thing it's
funny like actually i've read so my
grandfather's letters from that period
when before the united states entered
the war after dunkirk and he's doing the
calculations on like america entering
the war and it just is just staggeringly
awful like because at that point also
the soviet union's not in the war
against germany right and so people are
talking about the united states entering
and
uh
it's like that's not they're not going
there's no way that there we could
possibly do this because it's just you
know us versus nazi germany and we're
having to invade on a seabourn invasion
which is a little crazy yeah which like
and hit my grandfather's conclusion like
this would be insane like we can't do it
man i mean if you think about it
storming the beaches was nuts
i think it would have made no sense at
all had the soviet union not already
been in the war and been you know
grinding up the german army
yeah i mean you know people often forget
how the communists save the world and
then they just malign those poor soviets
soviets but that's actually something
i know hey man we helped in world war ii
and it's like yeah but you like killed a
ton of people before world war ii so it
doesn't make you the good guys yeah also
forgetting the fact that they were the
ones who wanted to keep working with
hitler until he betrayed them yeah right
operation barbarossa when the germans
went into went into russia
they were like hey wait you're not
supposed to attack us i guess we have no
choice yeah i think it's funny like how
many how many tens of millions of people
did the u.s kill in the early 1900s was
it none
i think so i mean i don't know obviously
people died at the hands of the united
states but it wasn't tens of millions
right well you had the nazis we know
what they did and yet the soviets we
know they did and then
here we are like let's team up with one
of them against the other it's the
weirdest it's the craziest thing to me
that like they're both just extremely
awful yeah but then we ended up having
to fight what 60 70 years a cold war
proxy wars all over the planet because
the soviets were very much bad guys yep
really i mean really it comes down to uh
you know the fact that hitler declared
war in the united states that like if
you're looking at the you know there was
another very fascinating bit of this
book that i thought was really
interesting there's that window between
december 7 1941 and i think four days
later where hitler declares war in the
united states and britain was freaking
out because they thought we were just
going to go to war with japan
and they that's where all our resources
were going to go that's where every all
the military investment was going to go
and britain was just going to have to
hold out nazi germany on its own
and then hitler declared war on us and
all of a sudden like they just
breathe a sigh of relief well i mean the
us was like we don't really need to
worry about war with japan because we
got nukes we need we need our ground
forces in europe
your timing's run we didn't have nukes
fully developed until like 45 um and
that it wasn't obvious in 1940
41 that that was going to be like a game
changer they had a meeting roosevelt uh
stalin and
churchill i think i think stalin was
evolved to where they might have just
been uh churchill and roosevelt they
decided that they were going to focus
american war efforts they were all
agreed on europe we're not we're not
we're going to worry about japan until
later well i mean they just agreed that
the united states would take the the
like the ore in japan and that some of
most of the american resources would go
but i mean we were still i mean we we
built a hell of a carrier force like we
we spent a lot of money and energy on
japan too i think strategically europe
was more allies and more forces to help
if you if you liberate europe you get
more assistance in the rest of the war
right and i mean i think it was
ultimately a priority i think like over
japan in the in the pacific theater uh
but japan still got a ton of attention
it's crazy how much japan lost because
they went to war in this way oh it was a
a horrible horrible decision they were
doomed from the outset in terms of their
industrial capacity i mean you know more
more nerdy stuff but like from basically
like we dwarfed their naval production
by like ten to one
um
just for their theater right like we
were able to also produce everything we
needed for europe and then dwarf japan's
naval production like 10 to one and uh
that's it's a naval war like carriers
are
you know carriers are everything
and we just you know they they produce
maybe like six workable carriers when we
produce like 50 or 60 or something i
mean it was just i heard that they were
on the verge of surrendering before we
dropped the bombs on them is that true
yeah well i mean
they were on the you know it's it's not
clear which caused the surrender which
it was the russians finally declaring
war on japan
or uh and deciding to invade through
manchuria um or the the bombs right
because the first bomb went off and they
didn't they didn't surrender yeah and
then russia declared war
i think it was i'm not sure of the exact
timing they may have been deciding after
the first bomb wow it may have been a
meeting of you know
the japanese saying like who do we want
to be occupied by
yeah they might that i think it was
really once the russians invaded i think
that might have been plus the bomb but
the russians invading was sort of like
oh we're screwed right we lose did they
organize the american government and the
russians like we're going to drop a bomb
when you invade like we're going at them
with everything i don't remember if that
was it i think honestly at that point
russia might have been opportunistic
because russia wanted a seat at the
table with japan to negotiate
territorial concessions and so stalin
might have been kind of opportunistic of
like oh this we think this war is
probably going to wrap up soon let's get
in on the game and ensure that our
territorial claims are respected let's
let's bring the war to a modern
conversation we have this from politico
quote we see the storm coming u.s
struggles to contain a deepening global
food crisis but in officials are
scrambling to limit the damage from
fast-spreading food shortages sparked by
russia's war in ukraine but they face
complex political and logistical
challenges i just want to say i i
certainly i've said it before putin has
a lot to blame for the escalating prices
the war it's a tit for tat and then also
you get sanctions now putin saying he's
not going to export agriculture unless
it's to a friendly nation you've got the
rising fertilizer costs all of this very
much starts from this war however food
costs were already skyrocketing well
before this war started food shortages
were already hitting everybody well
before this war started i definitely
think the biden admin and the media are
like it's all putin's fault it's like
nah it's your fault too
but ladies and gentlemen i hope you're
prepared for the worst because they're
saying the word famine now it was the
french foreign minister said global
famine the i think it was the un health
food program said i don't know if you
said famine
but even biden is saying famine in
europe famine is the word oh boy well i
think it's more like famine in africa
right the problem being that it's food
resources in europe are like one of our
like key to providing food in africa
this is the surface layer you know
vladimir putin says the poorest
countries are going to be impacted very
heavily by this global food shortage
but of course it's going to impact us
very severely it already is
in spain they're already food rationing
in germany prices are already up uh 20
to 50 percent so this is the funny thing
you know you just had a look when i said
spain was doing food rationing they're
doing at supermarkets i want you guys to
imagine this imagine what your life is
going to be like when you go to a
supermarket and you go to get chicken
and there's a sign saying only one
chicken item per customer could you
imagine that i could because it happened
two years ago we saw all of these food
shortages and our supermarkets were
doing food rationing you'd go in and say
only one beef item per customer i went
in and i was like i want to get some
boneless chicken wings
they're called wangs or whatever because
they can't call them wings and it was
like a big sign says only two per
customer so you could get like one thing
of nuggets and maybe a thing of breast
that's all they would allow
worst thing that happening in europe now
it's happening in spain
germany as i mentioned prices are
skyrocketing so
with the fur with the lack of fertilizer
it's not just going to be poor nations
that suffer oh they're going to suffer
the worst yes but i'm very much
concerned about what's going to happen
here in the u.s what's going to happen
to cities when these people who are
entitled
often morbidly obese how are they going
to deal with this how are they going to
you know what are they going to do when
they can't get the food they want
hopefully they'll be they'll be looking
up on the internet how to lose weight
how to fast because the first three or
four days of fasting is brutal but this
is like you know this is different like
you know the covet stuff hit our supply
chain right this is europe's no it's our
supply chain we we get a ton of our
fertilizer from russia
most of our fertilizer comes from russia
and fertilizer costs for american
farmers up 300 percent that's that's
fair i didn't realize that
and not to mention uh fuel costs too but
it also means what what will what will
the bite administration do for europe
biden's already talked about taking our
food and giving it away to other
countries so we are going to be strained
on this one
now the worrying thing is
people in big cities
la
is so massively dense and the people who
live in these dense populated areas they
don't make food
they you got house after house at their
house there's maybe a small garden but
these people aren't gonna be able to
sustain themselves in these big cities
what are they gonna do
now i don't think the apocalypse is
coming i don't think it's gonna be like
come november you go in the supermarket
there's people punching each other for
one can of beans maybe at some point the
next few years depending on how how bad
things can get but it's going to be like
what the way they're describing it is
food costs going up 40 by the end of the
year
with with inflation on top last night i
had a dream that i went i saw the owner
of the old restaurant that i worked at
in la i saw her and i was like do you
own this restaurant she went yeah and i
get some food i sat down to get like a
reuben sandwich and it was a hundred
dollars in the dream and i didn't think
like uh oh and crazy i've been thinking
about inflation lately but that's just
like lightning struck my brain dude we
went out to get breakfast out here and
for like five people it was like a
hundred and something dollars
and we went to a diner we didn't go to
like a crazy place
prices were nuts i mean prices you even
just go to the grocery store try and buy
a pound of ground beef it's like seven
eight bucks easy there's there's a
little barbecue shack by us and last
year they stopped selling brisket and
the guy said it was because it was too
expensive he was like there's no point
in trying to sell a 20 serving of
brisket no one will buy it and then i
got and then i'm on the hook for it so i
just won't buy it at all do you guys
think that you will eat bugs you will
live in the pot you think factory
farming is a sin against god
uh well i'm not religious so we'll start
there um
so that's uh i it's a shameless question
i was going to ask sheamus i i'm not
sure how you're defining factors i
believe there i believe there are ways
that are more or less ethical when it
comes to how we treat animals i was
taking the stink bugs out of my room and
throwing them outside and like they were
dying in the freezing and i asked god am
i gonna burn in hell for killing these
things and he said you're gonna
if you're gonna judge you for anything
it's for factory farming and it was like
all of you it was the statement of like
the human race will be judged harshly
for what you're doing to the animals in
factory farms
i believe it if there is a god that he'd
be pissed or it would be not happy with
the dis unity and the disorganization of
how we've corralled these things stuck
them with antibiotics to overgrow them
and just suck their but listen listen i
mean i will i will agree with you to a
certain extent just in a basic human
moral position that we do bad things in
in the name of profit to maximize how
much food we produce and now we have
very very cheap food and very very fat
homeless people so there is definitely
some weird disconnect going on with our
food economics at the same time we need
mass production of food to feed people
so they can live i'm into the stem cell
food have you guys looked well i don't
want to change the subject
you know maybe on the afternoon let's
operate with the assumption that we
don't have it right now should we
continue i mean and i think
you know it's not ultimately it's not
the chicken and beef that are making
people fat right it's yeah it's the
sugar in the carbs
corn sugar the corn the corn industry
you know what it was for me i'm so
michaela peterson talks about how uh
just switching to an all-meat diet it's
not so much that all meat diet is good
for you but it's but that it's an
elimination diet so when i cut out carbs
i cut out bread too
and then i've been having some food and
then testing it turns out when i eat no
gluten my whoop recovery rate is through
the roof when i have bread it drops so
i'm like that's it bread's done we had
that same conversation last night yeah
exactly so when you when you do an all
meat diet yeah that's good you're
getting your b vitamins you're getting
it but it's all the stuff that you're
cutting out the sodium benzoate the
crappy uh preservatives that they don't
even put on the label that they call
natural flavors you know that they get
from like a dissected bug or something
you know what you know what i ate today
out in the yard we have chives
everywhere
everywhere it's amazing they taste so
good it's nuts you can pick them off the
ground and eat them i prefer to wash
them so i don't do that but literally we
walk outside and just grab a big thing
and just tear it off and then chop it up
threw it in some farm fresh ground beef
we got from a farm down the road nice
man that was that's that's good eating
people i bring this up because when you
look at places like l.a or new york what
are they going to do
when food you know food is harder to
come by there was a movement to start
growing vegetables in the berm area of
uh la streets i don't know if you guys
saw that there's a guy pushing for it
four or five years ago like the middle
of the streets where they have like the
planters yeah between the sidewalk and
the road you know why that won't work
because people will just take it no
because it would fall on the ground rot
and then bugs come yeah
all over the streets
but if you could upkeep it like you
could the homeless people you could give
them money that's a job incentive
program to keep up keep the gardens and
just having that you can't see that yeah
i mean how most people aren't or anybody
really that wanted a job the problem is
not yeah that's shellenberger right he's
really good on this the prob the problem
with homeless people is not the lack of
the home i shouldn't even just say
homeless like that that's just they need
or want that it's anybody that could use
a job that could be a type of job as
local farms road farms or whatever you
want to call them but they are going to
run out of food if they don't
i don't know i mean i mean like most of
those sort of like urban gardening type
things are
not don't make sense in terms of scale
right the problem i mean you they just
don't understand how big like the farms
that actually feed us really are they're
massive
and you know when you're talking about
these small tiny little urban plots it's
like a you know yeah exactly and like
the most population is just a trivial
tree a trivial contribution to the
overall food supply i like road or
rooftop gardens but they're cool they're
just not that meaningful in terms of
increasing the food supply of a city it
could like supplement your groceries
basically but if everyone does it i mean
it's a big ask i know to grow your own
food i mean it's kind of like duh
looking back and be like they didn't
used to grow their own so what the heck
i was reading one article that said
people should expect to be spending
about a thousand dollars a month for
groceries
what what what is do we know the average
spend for a family per month on
groceries
i can look that up look it up
because uh
for me
i don't i don't i don't have a good
barometer of a high gross grocery cost
because when we buy groceries we buy for
the whole office which is like 30 people
so we spend a lot restocking everything
for everybody but i'm wondering what the
average person is spending per month on
groceries
it was 200 a week according to 2020 data
uh from the u.s bureau of labor
statistics that works out to 412 dollars
per month
so it's gonna it's gonna more than so at
least one article is reading was saying
expect your bills to your your food
costs to be about over a thousand
dollars i read that people should budget
an extra fifty two hundred dollars per
year for inflation starting so an extra
500 or so bucks for the food costs
yup we got this story from you today get
ready to spend more at the grocery store
food price is expected to soar
usda so here's the thing on top of the
economy being in absolute shambles and
people being more panicked about their
ability to access food for the first
time than they've ever been in our
lifetimes this complete disaster uh
the democrats decide you know what on
top of this you know what we need
politically we need to defend grooming
i know i feel like no no no no no
they're like how do we get people to
stop talking about the fact they can't
buy food
defend something unconscionable
you're right they should be focusing on
sustained local food growth like as a
human it should be like a human thing
that the american government should be
supporting a movement to teach people
how to locally grow their own food we
have we have uh pawpaw season out here
so end of september october there is so
much pawpaw that it's just rotting
everywhere and it's paw paw it's like if
you took a banana a mango and avocado
and mix it all together so it's this
like round green fruit that grows it's
apparently hard to cultivate because
only like beetles and flies pollinate
the flowers but they're they're
everywhere so i was really excited to
try it for the first time it tastes like
a banana avocado mango and just mixed
together so you can make bread with it
you can it's it's all over the place i
just want i want to point out man how
amazing it is when you're not in a city
because this is something i think city
people don't realize because i didn't
realize it and all the country people
are sitting back with that straw in
their mouth laughing because they're
like yeah there's food everywhere so i
go outside there's chives we take the
chives it makes our food taste good then
we have the berry season where there's
blackberries and wine berries everywhere
you go outside for 10 minutes and you've
got like two pounds of fresh berries and
it's amazing you do everything with it
it's just delicious obviously you need
more than that but it's just it's crazy
growing up growing up in a city and not
realizing you can just eat stuff outside
it's just nuts people in cities aren't
able to do this
and also people in cities unfortunately
don't know where their food comes from
and i think this is why we have folks
who unfortunately think that a small
garden like that can sustain their city
or make a significant dent here
there was a hilarious article it was it
was actually a letter to the editor and
i've quoted it here before on the show
but somebody basically
wrote to their newspaper saying that it
was offensive that they printed an
article which discussed hunting because
people should just be getting their food
from the grocery store where no animals
are harmed
or i've mentioned how i got an argument
with a guy during uh the primaries when
i was talking about with with you know
how ubi would disrupt the economy and
with the shortages eventually there's
not gonna be any milk at the grocery
store and some guy was like what do you
mean you just go to the grocery store to
get the milk it's just there and then i
was like you realize it's bottled and
sent there right it's like it's just at
the grocery store what do you mean
well then there's no these people
genuinely don't realize magic no they're
dumb well the milk the dairy is
harvested it's set to various processing
plants for a variety of things cream
half and half sour cream yogurt milk all
the stuff it has to get separated out
right homogenization process then it
goes to bottling and packaging plants
then it goes to like warehouse
distribution then it goes to stores yeah
well and also i mean people
are gonna point to russia the political
leaders are obviously the main reason
this is happening is because they
decided to shut down the supply chain
back in 2020 there were instances where
there were certain foods that we had
shortages of even though that particular
food didn't have a hiccup in its
production or quite as much of a hiccup
to lead to the proportional shortage
that we were seeing because the
government even though they declared
food production to be essential declared
the production of items that were
required for the packaging of that food
to be non-essential so the food was
produced but it could just never get to
the grocery store oh my gosh
yeah i've been working with this company
called eden growth systems that's
developing they have some nasa
technology and you can basically grow
indoors and the idea is four of these
towers can sustain one person
indefinitely but i don't know if a if a
capitalist movement like buy this
product i'm about to start using it so
i'm really excited to see the value like
you can grow eggplants and stuff um you
you've got to have your own guard at the
very least you know
when i lived in new york there was no
way to have a garden it was impossible i
could have a garden box with maybe one
plant and maybe have like a tomato but
that's that's that's that's nothing
that's why i'm like you know what people
who live in the cities you do your thing
look at this story we got from raw story
iowa's bird flu death toll tops 13
million
this is there's a pandemic happening
among chickens
but it means eggs will be more expensive
it means chicken meat's going to be
harder to come by and we already saw the
chicken wing shortage during the
pandemic likely likely to happen again
especially with the global food
shortages that are coming so i brought
up stem cell meat i believe that we're
headed towards a feature where we don't
eat farm animals like this that's going
to be really really good there's no fat
curious
about this so obviously you know we have
a pitched picture of a chick in here
which creates the mental connection that
the
birds dying from this are livestock but
how are they getting this 13 million
number is it chickens that are dying is
it is it chickens that are dying
it's it's i believe specifically okay
okay poultry uh poultry flocks in iowa
this has been big news so we've actually
we we've been warned just to make sure
we quarantine any chickens we get
outside because we have we have our
chickens we have like 50 now because we
bred a whole bunch and so we were told
by a breeder like any chickens you get
keep them separated for 30 days which is
kind of a normal thing because you don't
want to spread diseases or whatever but
right now it's fairly serious
we got chickens
chickens lay eggs all the time it's
fantastic we got too many eggs too many
we had in like one week we had 74 eggs
i don't even know we just made a whole
bunch of these great deviled eggs so
yeah yeah those are awesome oh man yeah
that was great i got to start eating
i wonder what percentage this is of the
the total livestock of chickens that we
have in the country it's just a lot no i
mean i agree it's frightening
i'm just saying it's it's things like
this that are all kind of happening
around the same time that are like you
pay attention to the stuff
uh
you know in 2015 a deadly bird flu
outbreak resulted in 32 million birds
and i would uh being cold
so they say iowa's affected birds this
year account for 59
of the country's current 22.4 million
total according to the u.s department of
agriculture and data hey you know what
so just about sixty percent of our
chickens this is also an indication of
the danger of centralized farming when
you have one yes
yeah have you built your own chicken
city and have them far away from each
other so that if one little batch gets
ill that's okay well you just keep
trying
chickens need to social
distances they might need our help you
should see the way they call these
chickens if you've never seen a video of
them calling chickens it's freaking
horrific i'm not gonna even talk about
it on on air because it's so disturbing
uh but it involves suffocation so i
guess i did talk about it on air i'll
get so i just so i feel for these
animals man look in their eyes they are
not npcs there's something going on
there humans eat meat i get it and i'm
not saying we shouldn't but there are
other ways to derive your meat than
growing and killing something for it i
know that's been the way that we've been
doing it for for
ever i think that's just like naivety
bro
i don't i'm not making it just it's not
like it's not a fantasy there's
technology backing it up i i always i
always liked the way the native
americans would go about it you know
you'd kill the animal and then you would
basically like have some sort of prayer
of like what you are getting from this
creature that you whose life you've
taken like there's like respect to life
but recognizing that we humans we
survive and we eat meat and i'm sorry
man i genui i think humans eat meat
that's it like there's a lot of people
who are like humans who actually don't
eat meat i think it was mostly fish but
humans eat meat yeah it's less about the
meat more about the suffering and the
the sickness that comes from factory
farm that i'm concerned and i i will say
this there is something about
you know
growing cultivating or even hunting your
own food i've you know i don't do it
often but i have gone hunting and when
you see the cost when you actually kill
an animal in order to get food from it
you don't waste it
you're way less likely to waste food we
waste food all the time because we just
go to the grocery store and get it and
we don't even have to consider the fact
that an animal died for it but you
understand inherently there's there's
this lack of gratitude there's this
disrespect in wasting food that most
people never acknowledge
thank you when we go out to eat
so much food gets wasted and what do you
do because i'm not talking about like
you order a steak and half of it here's
like i'm not eating half that steak ever
again i mean like a couple bites here
and there and that that really really
adds up
yeah if we were actually in like a
famine situation nothing would be wasted
you'd be you'd be you'd be boiling tree
bark if you were starving well i mean
it's just like a different i mean it
would completely change the culture
right like you read about like people
who grew up in the great depression just
hoarding like just not just food right
stuff uh because it's like well you
never know how you might need to use
this and that was much more common when
i was 18
i was hanging out with my grandpa
and i was i made a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich with his bread and then i
saw there was mold on the bread
and then i was like ah i'm not going to
eat it and he's like why not and i was
like there's a mold on he goes you know
during the depression and then he grabs
it and he just like
just eats the whole thing and i was like
you can at least take the mold off yeah
he didn't care you get sick from that
man i don't know what kind of mold was
it do you remember just blue i don't
know blue mold those black molds very
dangerous blue green yellow i think
penicillin's white mold yeah but mold's
still bad don't want to eat it but uh
you know his point was like during the
during the depression they would eat
whatever they could
you eat what you can get
we
you know i hear stories about the
depression i don't think we've seen
anything like that no no matter how bad
things have gotten no no and i mean
it's hard it's it's doubtful that we
would honestly like there's there's a
level of
uh
i don't know just like how developed our
economy is it's really hard to imagine
something i mean we forget how
relatively undeveloped things were in
that period in large portions of the
country
um people need to realize the these
systems can be knocked down very easily
yeah i mean you mean you you can screw
them up for a longer period i don't know
i i guess i'm more of an optimist on
than you guys on that front like i just
you know you read about what things were
really like in the great depression and
not just and not just i'm talking about
like rural areas like rural
electrification was still like not
really a thing you know um you know
i think a really good book if anybody
wants to read about this is actually the
first serie in the series of biographies
of lyndon johnson because lyndon johnson
grew up in hill country texas in like
poor and it was poor i mean you know
what we would consider like worse than
poverty poor then um and you realize how
far things have come like in rural areas
especially in terms of like in basic
infrastructure clean water clean water
is a huge part of it south america you
could see i went down there and i was
helping clean the amazon out and we were
with these tribes this one truck they
weren't really tribes they're just in
bail in any quito and they didn't know
that poop water was bad for you so
they'd defecate in the water and then
drink it and they'd distended stomachs
and like
not only was the education lacking so
yes clean water but also education we
need maintain access to at least maybe
electricity and internet so that we can
continue to educate kids properly i
think maybe um yeah
maybe we need some kind of uh a way to
just get things to to to go back to
baseline
so that we can kind of figure out how
much food people really yeah you're
talking about like a recess yeah that's
a great reset
of the whole global system really be
great if nobody owned anything for that
i would be happy much easier to move
things around you should be happy yeah
yeah i'd be happy yeah you could spin up
a
corporation maybe that surrounds
yourself that's surrounded around that
idea maybe we can do some kind of
organization about like global economics
have like a forum i was just a year
ago oh my goodness yes the world forum
of economic on economics a world foreign
economics the world's
[Laughter]
boring numbers that could have rolled
right there i wanna i wanna make sure
that uh you know we saw shortages we saw
prices increase
i've been going to the grocery store and
the prices have definitely been going
way up consistently very quickly and so
my concern is
are we seeing from the media and the
bi-administration fear-mongering i don't
know why they would want to do that
right now considering elections are
coming up
are people experiencing normalcy bias
and optimism bias meaning it can't
happen
or something like that will never happen
right the optimism bias is like no that
couldn't happen and normalcy is like
well that's never happened so
everything's gonna stay the same and i'm
not gonna have to worry about it
or are we gonna see something dramatic
like we've not seen in a long time like
ground war in europe
fertilizer shortages
i think
at the very least we should expect to
see
africa
starvation is going to get nuts i'm glad
that biden said the word famine because
it's people like my parents that need to
hear it from the authority to really
start taking it seriously
maybe they'll buy extra beans or
something we need peace in russia and
ukraine geez i don't know like that
should there's a lot of people who want
to keep the war going to drain russia as
though it's like a cold war and we need
to do that you know we need to just
strain them out in afghanistan right no
no no we need peace we want peace
between russia yeah
take it when you can get it because in a
war if something changes with the
leadership one day there's no that
that's off the table now like at some
psycho not that putin's not i'm not
saying he's a psycho but some real
genuine cycle like a putin gets
assassinated and some crazy oligarch
gets a hold you may never see an option
for peace again i think i think you know
once we have the piece everyone should
just not own anything and be happy yeah
i would say so i mean that yeah
absolutely
and then there's like someone who tuned
into the show for the first time like
i hear a lot of good things about this
tim pool guy
i don't want to watch this show ever
again
all right let's pull these super chats
if you have not already we implore you
smash that like button do it for eaton
he needs those likes
he ian goes to bed and he's like we
didn't get enough likes man he cries and
then you know and then we gotta deal
with it that's true and it keeps
everyone up too like yeah you can hear
me crying yeah you cried loud
i start screaming and punching the walls
sheamus shaped fists holes in the wall
coming through the wall and
and imprints of his face in the wall
from bashing his face screaming so loud
you can see a spirit imprinted on the
wall all right uh subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have that members only show coming
up at 11 p.m over at timcast.com
let's see what we got here
raymond g stanley jr says nyc adams is
spending tax money on billboards in
florida yep really yeah what about so he
therefore to move people backwards yeah
baby come back yep yeah
with a boombox man come back to me
dude states are competing for citizens
i've never seen this before well they're
losing them all right bailey and says
tim you should watch nick ricketta's
breakdown of the chad reed shooting
because you missed a lot due to the
media leaving a lot of context i can
believe that for sure i'm sure rocato
went through like the actual uh
paperwork and legal filings and stuff
like that
all right crayson says if you're looking
for a word to describe the left and the
west in general by this point look to
your family pet the word is simple
domesticated
yes i agree i think that we've we are
being domesticated we are being told to
be children permanently well speak for
yourself i'm not
you're you guys well i'm another one
here i'm a wild man i punched the wall
when ian cries that's right that's right
where are the likes
if you guys don't leave likes and i end
up having to punch the wall again i'm
not going to be able to finish
tomorrow's cartoon because my hand's
going to be broken so please like the
video all right nanad sregek says love
when will is on but i need to know his
thoughts on star trek the malice episode
black black pilled me on him well i i
don't i don't really watch star trek so
sorry uh
is that how did how did it blackfill me
is it like suddenly is it a podcast i
did with him where i said i don't really
know much about star trek or i'm more of
a star wars person i don't know why why
they're concerned about you as michael
malus was saying star trek was just like
for nerds and he didn't like it which is
weird because he's such a big dc guy
and like
first i just want to clarify too you
know a nerd is a reference to
academia and a geek is a reference to
fandom and you know the difference
absolutely of course i like because you
know
you're a geek
i like spy novels so i don't in spy
movies so read read john licorae and
watch stuff like the spy who came in
from the cold and tinker taylor soldier
spy you'll you won't regret it
all right
awesome archivist says is it so hard to
have a hobby why do so many
link purpose to what society demands of
you ultimately these physically
intangible concepts concepts sjw's
obsess over do not exist sincerely a 22
year old well they need a religion
substitute that's what they need
is they're yep need a religion
substitute i think mark andreason maybe
said something smart today where he's
like the best way to have a religion
indoctrinated schools is to just not
call it a religion and then all of a
sudden you can do it andrew l says tim
in your monologue today you mentioned
having a deep freezer and how the food
could last forever what about an
extended power outage so we have a
hamster that runs in a wheel and it
charges the job it's a big hamster
we spent uh decades doing genetic
engineering to make a big enough hamster
to power a deep freezer and we got it
his name's velvet well done
melvin melvin yeah so uh we have here
that is true facts there is an issue if
the power goes out and it has and it's a
deep freezer so it will last for a
decent amount of time without thawing
out and there are things you can do to
check like you put like some you know a
piece of ice in it and then if you come
back and you get a flat disc of ice you
know that it melted and re-froze but um
we are getting solar installed and at
the new facility we have an obscene
amount of solar power because we want to
be
independent which means we're going to
have satellite internet we're going to
have solar power we have an insane
amount of batteries so the how the whole
facility can be powered for like a week
or longer if there's no sun at all like
let's say there's just like storms for a
week straight and the power goes out we
will still have power for like a week
and then we have well water obviously
and heavy duty filtration systems so
yeah not because i think that the world
will end but because i'm concerned that
sometimes snow storms hit and then the
power goes out and you should just be
able to take care of yourself just
thinking could we cover that deep
freezer with blankets if the power were
to go out to hold the cold inside it's
all it's a deep freezer it's already
insulated
so there's no more added insulation we
could add to help it you know i don't
i'm sure you could put in a vacuum or
something
i don't know considering that it's
insulated when we had we had a fuse go
out and it was out for a while
everything was still deeply frozen i
mean when you take meat out of the deep
freezer it's it's hard to thaw you know
i guess we just put a lock on it so if
the power goes out it locks you know
what full is going on no we just
we have a bunch of these batteries you
can't see them but they're all over the
studio they're these huge batteries what
are they called
ef delta is that what it's called those
are great yeah they're fantastic and
when we we were we were doing a show
once when the power went out and then we
just we have the tech crew come and they
plug all these things in and then we
have a really big one too so we have
backup power for days
all right
roger shek snyder says love sheamus and
freedom tunes thank you so much don't we
all don't we all i'm so glad to hear
that well for those of you who who are
not familiar with who this sheamus is or
what freedom tunes are go over to
freedom tunes youtube.com freedomtunes
hit subscribe hit the bell we're
uploading a cartoon tomorrow i love you
so much
cigars and sig arms says can we just go
back to the days where he-man and orco
warned kids about the things groomers
would do to children and told them to
tell their parents or police officers if
it happened to them deeply homophobic
neptunes they would be too much time
don't tell your parents what we're doing
exactly if they made it today if someone
talks i mean i would love to do that i
think it's important for kids to know if
someone touches you in a place that
you're not comfortable that you scream
and you push them away that's what my
parents taught me
and in it of course if if an adult
says anything to you that they tell you
not to repeat to your parents you
immediately go and repeat it to your
parents yes donald t says groundhog day
but the cast castle has to get ian the
right cake to break the time loop that
was some good acting ian you had me
fooled forever oh did they release that
today oh that was up a couple days ago
it was funny so basically like ian comes
down and there's a cake and then he gets
mad and you guys gotta watch pink is a
lie but then but then ian storms off and
then shane is like i can't believe he we
thought he'd liked it let's try again
pulls out another cake goes hey ian and
ian walks down all happy like nothing
happens brilliantly directed by sheamus
like i wasn't the only one
a lot of talented people involved with
this shoot matthew hammond says can we
get north carolina lieutenant governor
mark robinson on the show he recently
had to call out a political cartoon in a
local newspaper depicting him a black
man in a clan outfit that was drawn by
an eighth grade social studies teacher
wow dude that video he is that guy's
hilarious he did that whole speech of
like a prophet where he's like
something like we need to start teaching
people to children to read and not teach
them how to go to hell
i just want to mention this as someone
who does make political cartoons i'll be
at animated ones the
person i don't like wearing a clans
hood is the laziest most overused trope
in political cartooning yeah it's hard
it doesn't shock me that what did it say
it was an eighth grader who drew this of
course no he's an eighth grade teacher
always an eighth grade teacher wow okay
even better the cognitive faculties of
an age grader apparently
yeah all right
reign again says if public schools had a
system to let kids get baptized take
communion and go through confirmation
with protocols to uh to hide this from
parents they would call it religious
grooming in a heartbeat absolutely yes
that is true
yep yes
all right dudley deplorable says back in
the 50s and 60s we had a grooming
teacher his activities were known
nothing was done children taught
children to practice themselves had to
edit to get past the ai hmm
wow
morgan h says the left says you hate
gays because they are used to slinging
insults saying racist homophobes etc the
right flinched but they're not flinching
anymore
well there you go just bill says i
listened almost daily so i thought i
should contribute hey thanks very much
bill appreciate it
logan angel
says have you guys heard about oregon's
is that lip
ip13 it would make basically anything
involving animals illegal and it's not
getting enough attention it's disguised
as an anti-animal abuse bill i heard it
was about hunting i don't know much
about it
they don't want you to have your own
animals
i wouldn't trust the oregon legislature
over everything so i assume any of their
bills are bad right that's just the
lefty legislature
alexander roscoe says at 17 in high
school i came out to my woke teacher one
night she took me across state lines
from new jersey to philadelphia's
gaborhood to show me gay culture when we
got back i was told not to tell my
parents creepy
i hope you did tell them that is
extremely creepy i hope you told them
yeah seriously if that happened yeah
that's another cat says cats don't mind
grooming
that's what i'm talking about they groom
themselves
some dogs are not fans of getting
groomed you know
all right what do we got here
dolphin seaweed says who pooed an ian's
cereal this morning that man seems like
he needs a hug i'm i i completely agree
with you i don't see this as a joke or
funny and the right is reacting not
being proactive at all
was did you do something again about
yourself i have been in kind of a tense
mood today i'm thanks for calling that
out
um yeah
just in general
what is this smile more says ian is spot
on bill gates wanted to use haptic
feedback sensors iris scanning as part
of common core parents found out and
fought like hell to make sure it did not
happen good job get ready to fight over
and over and over and over again as they
continue to attempt to
indoctrinate humans into the metaverse
in in 10 years the lgbtq communist
republican party is going to be like
it's a slippery slope with the metaverse
and we don't agree to it then 10 years
later it's going to be the metaverse
republicans arguing
in hyperspeed metaverse language about
some other you'll have nine year olds
that are making more money than their
parents and then they'll start donating
to campaigns and the politicians are
going to be given over these
metaversions
lunar transport says does all this talk
of conversion and grooming mean that
homosexuality is a learned behavior
wasn't it the talking point that you are
born that way i think there is a
dissonance dissonance of messaging here
yeah that's that's been been obvious
obvious for the past several years i
mean isn't it like a little i mean
there's a nature component and a nurture
component that's my understanding i
think so well
now now they're saying uh many leftists
are saying not all of them but a lot of
them that
if you are attracted to women but won't
sleep with a trans woman you're
transphobic yeah
so like jazz jennings's brother recently
came out and said that he is
heterosexual but
because trans women are women he would
be attracted to them and i'm just like
doesn't that mean you're bisexual
exactly i don't understand why there's
an aversion of bisexual people to claim
they're not they're just
heterosexual i don't i still i ask this
question often like what makes a person
gay is it the actual act of sex with
someone of the same sex or is it the
desire and without ever doing the action
it depends on who you ask because uh
i've been told by you know friends of
mine who are gay that it's the emotional
connection they have that's what i feel
like it would be yeah because they're
like
there are people who are who are
extremely
what's the right word just like
going to dungeons and doing crazy things
with weird great like if a guy is
dressed up like a horse and like another
guy he is like a fairy godmother you
know you what are you what are you what
are you doing and so their their view of
things is it's about emotional
connection
but if that's the case like i i that
that that doesn't make sense because
bisexual implies it is sexual yeah what
sexual orientation is being sexually
attracted to fairy godmothers
they'll they'll make one up i don't know
if you don't know
if you google it right now i bet you
find it
fairy godmothers
they watch like uh cinderella and they
just have it pause on that one scene
with the fairy godmother
well hey man magic file or something you
get down with wizards fairy god
magicio file they have like they hire
someone to dress up like albus
dumbledore
harry potter you're a wizard
all right all right all right
free men die free says a 4chan user
years ago accurately described in great
detail how the alphabet community would
be used to push keto acceptance i have
the screenshots and they're spot on
interestingly there was a bunch of
people trying to push lgbtp
yes and the left claimed it was a hoax
campaign
but these people are serious
they've been serious they call
themselves maps
minor attracted threats there was a
slate article right slate published an
article by a map quote-unquote a
pedophile being like actually you know
it's just a sexual orientation yeah
exactly so again and this goes with that
well this goes without saying all right
but
it we have this republican
using the term li tinx
no one ever used the term map
unironically in fact they don't even use
it ironically just call them pedophiles
right
all right let's read some more
latter-day gamer says f my state and the
rhinos that rule it cox literally
blindsided the state no history of this
kind of stuff before he became governor
well there it is you know
now he's using his pronouns
that's why i don't trust the republican
party
because unless you know even if you do
primary people you don't know who you're
going to get you can trust that they're
going to be good and they're going to do
all the right things and as soon as they
get in office there you go keep voting
them out they keep coming in
shane parr says tim is a father of four
children i just have to say that i am
with you 100
if people don't start standing up for
their values they're going to lose their
kids in jobs anyway good people can't
remain silent let's let's let's
elaborate on that when i ask the
question
you're a father with children you're a
mother with children would you rather
have a job knowing that your child is
being groomed eight hours a day but at
least you have money and you're set
you're secure or be homeless
with your child not knowing where your
food comes from
now let's say you opt for
i'm okay with my job and these people
grooming my kids are you then okay
when someone comes to you and they have
your kid in a child drag show and when
you complain child services comes and
takes your child from you
so what happens if you wait around
if you don't don't take action someone
else is gonna take it for you exactly
it's not as if the left wins one of
these you know they they further degrade
our culture and then go we're done we're
done we're just gonna stop there things
are bad enough we won't make it worse we
won't restrict your rights as a parent
more so you gave us what we wanted no
it's only gonna get worse all right
donnie ronald says fellow utah in here
mormons and rapid uh and rapid growth is
what's wrong with utah there is a lot of
business here in utah and unfortunately
it's attracting snakes mormons
they're religious though wouldn't they
when they push back yeah i mean
mormons that that's the foundation of
utah is the
church like it's just deeply embedded in
in the entire upper crust of i mean
that's that's where the mormons went
with joseph smith that's they went to
salt lake city
gino benedetto says i'm a navy vet going
to school for engineering on the back of
my truck is written what country is this
and then and why are the people all ugly
i don't get a lot of hate messages but
it's hilarious to me oh man youtube's
not gonna like that one
that's funny all right let's see
whoosh says utah in here the state is
very red but salt lake city provo is
aggressively left check r utah 90 of it
is absolute vitriol against any
conservative and provo is where that blm
guy shot the driver for no reason
remember that
no someone was driving down the street
and blm was running through the streets
and then some guy just ran up to the
passenger side window and then put a
bullet in the driver
i don't ask i have no idea why man two
men were arrested in that apparently
yeah going to thedesert.com
deseret.com seriously jk says tim tell
us about your sweet sweet flash
animations please um there's not really
much to tell i made a video game once
where it was like a guy running through
a factory and that was it there was no
real story to it
and then there was like i made
metal things that would like you know
slam down and you had to like run under
them and then there i there are these
little uh little uh wind-up guys like
that munched like
i need to jump over them and that was
about it and then you collect once you
collect all the coins that the door
would open and you could go to the next
level it was it was a pretty crummy game
and then i just would copy and paste the
levels and move stuff around and keep
you know that's basically basically it
that was fun those old actions i made
websites though i made a few flash
websites for for some of my friends and
for me and
was about it flash was fun motion tween
back in flash four yeah yeah
i started with flash three got a used
copy of it on ebay
flash man good software but i was i
started making videos because i was
skateboarding so then i started doing
video editing and stuff
so there you go right
all right let's grab some more let's
grab some more super chats
prometheus says drop pronouns entirely i
wonder if the daily wire would consider
making anime potentially a biblical
anime
they should it's like two points well
there here's what actually i think
should be like we should just have a
general agreement so so the left does
this thing where they're like
gender is a social construction and
they're saying it is that this novel
insight it's like no that
gender you literally invented the
concept as a construction right like it
it was if you go back to the 1920s and
how the word gender was used it was only
used in relation to like pronouns and
language right like uh or gender gender
terms like how in romance languages like
there's
uh you know l and la for the prefix or
whatever like you invented it as a
social construction so like why don't we
just realize that maybe we don't need to
use pronouns on the basis of a social
construction and can said use it on the
basis of biological reality and thus
always refer to people by their
biological sex what if i just call
everyone it
you know like when like ian's like hey
can you hand me that i'll be like will
it's asking for it
so
i want to mention this not only is
gender identity an invented term a
social construct that the left put
forward to try to blur the lines between
the sexes it was coined by dr john money
now i'm not sure if you guys are
familiar with history was i know the
word the word gender identity uh and
gender role and sexual orientation were
all coined by dr john he's that guy who
tortured those two kids into killing him
yes he's yes he's so basically there was
a botched circumcision that
occurred and there were there were there
were twins there was a botched
circumcision on one of them he
encouraged the parents to raise the
child who had undergone the botched
circumcision as a girl and said that he
was going to remove this child's
genitals he did they tried to raise the
the child as a girl he always knew that
there was something wrong with him
always understood at some
level johnson money-making
and he forced them to engage in sexual
behavior as children and he snapped
pictures of it this guy was just a child
sex abuser he was a pedophile he's the
person who coined the terms gender
identity and gender both those
individuals ended up killing themselves
yes whoa yes
and that's where that comes from
all right
carl covert says greg abbott is bussing
undocumented immigrants to dc he signed
the executive order today but they have
to fly but they have to volunteer yeah
if they volunteer to go okay yeah i was
thinking we talked about this before the
show that maybe it's uh if people can't
we're like coyote across the border this
is a way for them to be like i want to
go back because they do have to
volunteer to get sent
insert name here says ian sf is not
norcal that dumpster is north la norcal
starts directly north of it and 70
percent of california's water originates
in the north while 80 percent of the
demand is in the south the state steals
our water we need a separation
david jefferson
southern oregon and northern like north
northern california you know they've
talked about diverting the the delta
to bring water down south to southern
california and i'm kind of just like for
a while i was like no no you can't do
that it'll destroy the bay and now i'm
like oh no oh wait it'll destroy the bay
but there's a whole other issue with the
delta smelt it's like an environmental
issue they have to flush tons of fresh
water through the san joaquin that's
that's a bs argument i went there i went
down there i talked to a bunch of people
i think that's just some some emotional
defense the reality is if that if we
actually diverted the the the delta
water to the south for fresh water use
it would cause uh salt water to flood
into the bay and that would destroy a
lot of the farms in in the bay area
so that's why you can't do it that's why
i'm like oh no
you know oh oh they're fresh water
because it gets it's brackish towards
you know because it's fresh water and
seawater
all right tim miners has split
california in half east and west
the eastern half can be absorbed into
arizona and nevada problem solved agreed
so
terrible idea no its own state the
eastern part which is a hard red state
why why would we give up the creation of
a red state that's a terrible idea two
reds have two more republican senators
a powerful state with all those farms
yeah
someone said tim people attracted to
fairy godparents is a croaker crocker
sexual
fairy godparents
[Laughter]
you remember uh fairly odd parrots no no
i gotta look this up no it was a cartoon
in the 2000s there were some memes that
came out of that
the if i had one meme
i sent that to youtube so youtube this
was a while ago back when that meme was
in vogue youtube hadn't sent me a 1 000
subscriber plaque and i had already had
like 200 000 subs at this point so i
sent them a meme of that except it was
this is where i put my subscriber blog
and they responded to me they're like
we're sorry let's talk to you about
getting your subscriber plaque because
it actually did so it worked
all right
isaac luck says tim i would 100 support
your coffee enterprise but only if you
call it tim cafe or the coffee beanie if
you need drink ideas i'd be happy to
help i was thinking i have some really
good ideas for drink ideas i was
thinking like latte
cappuccino that's a good one
ice latte
get this mocha mocha
no frills okay i'm going to open a
sandwich shop and it's going to have
sandwich that's it
have you ever tried a breve i feel like
you would love it a brave what's that
made of breve is instead of using milk
they use either half and half or heavy
cream yes i've had i've had that before
wow cream is good yeah
my whole life i thought that it was the
sour cream that was making me fat at
taco bell when it turned out it was the
64-ounce sodas i was drinking and so i
thought cream was dangerous and now
recently i'm just learning i'm gonna
open a sandwich shop and it's gonna and
you're gonna have like three meats
lettuce tomato onion cheese mayo mustard
and you picked it it'll be here to
source the stuff that's for sure keep it
simple super simple super fast you come
and get a sandwich eat the food you get
out of there huh no no no no chit chat
no no nonsense no frilly garbage on the
walls it'll be very simple real men
coming in saying i want a sandwich
turkey do it done boom here you go
fresh made bread yeah
no games flour and water nothing else
nothing else maybe a man sandwich that
would be terrible
yeah i'm interested in getting different
types of creams for the coffee maybe an
almond cream a coconut cream no those
are frills
you drink cow you come to my coffee shop
we have heavy cream what about the
lactose intolerant no sorry get out do a
little peanut butter actually i actually
do feel like not tolerated in this house
because i was looking for food and
literally everything is like some sort
of like dairy product yeah no we we put
extra lactose in everything yeah we got
we got salami downstairs you have that i
can't eat salami that's true i found
some peanuts that was that oh those are
your snacks we've got uh in terms of
snacks not everything is dairy well i
guess the protein bars are dairy yeah oh
no not the outright ones i don't think
those are dairy no those are very i
looked at them they all have like i just
need some like clif bars or something
next time because everything's made of
protein so it's all yeah it's all like
the keto stuff yeah the cutest type of
dairy have you been vegan we have bacon
no no i mean i just i'm i'm meat and but
no dairy we have individually wrapped
bacon i do oh i saw those they're great
yeah really good i like the spicy one
spicy ones good yeah super good let's
read some more super jets
okay let's see let's grab a super cheer
here
a sim solution says tim the water issue
with california farmers having all the
water stolen for la is nothing new it
was a central point in the 1974 film
noir chinatown starring jack nicholson
set in the late 1930s
chinatown's like i mean
i forget the like details of the plot
but it's sort of you know investigating
this sort of corruption like a private
investigators jack nicholson's character
and he's investigating this like
corruption slash murder and a big chunk
of the drama revolves around water water
rights in california
nugget says i was born in zimbabwe 1991.
they took land from white people divided
it up and gave it to africans then
everyone starved because nobody knew how
to farm whoa that's what happens with
communism yep they're like the people
should own the land yay
get rid of the farmer yay does anybody
know how to farm no
and then you die yay
or they're like quick everyone melt down
your tools to make pig iron yeah yeah
they want to do that with south africa
too land reform oh yeah yeah that's been
a that's that's
south africa man
having like farmers been getting
attacked in mass in south africa
the depends on who you ask the corporate
press is like that's not happening so it
probably is yeah it's definitely
happening
but uh
what the media says is all farmers are
being attacked but they were thinking it
was like the white colonial farmers that
were being attacked that's the story
there's there's there is a place in
south africa this was from lauren
southern's documentary where it's like
all white and like white only or
something
it's crazy like that something like that
still exists and it's like a weird
pocket suburban town far away from
everything i think they they almost like
they applied to be like a minority
protected status or something like that
in south africa i remember i remember
reading about that place it was
very weird
all right
let's grab some more super chats
uh let's see what does that say
mr messenger message writer says you say
the cities will be worse for food
shortages you have no idea many west
coast cities have thousands of people
living in 100 square foot apartments
which have no storage no kitchen they
must leave to get food to eat
oh yeah the bachelors when i lived in la
and i was trying to find a place to live
i ended up living with a friend of mine
in a studio and it was a couple hundred
it was it was it was like 500 square
feet maybe and so it was just a studio
but it had a separate kitchen and so i
was like all right that's cool
when i was looking for places for myself
i couldn't afford any of these things i
had to split a studio but they had
bachelor apartments which are basically
glorified closets and then there's one
shared bathroom that everyone uses and
it was still like several hundred
dollars per month and i was just like
man
i did not want to live here at that
point i would try and live in like my
my band lockout or something but i lived
in a band space once it's like 100 bucks
a month paper thin walls
rickety old building probably full of
all like asbestos or whatever you name
it i was in chicago that was fun though
no no good lighting you'd wake up and
there was no showers or anything so
you'd go to the bathroom and just splash
water on yourself but hey a hundred
bucks a month and a place to sleep i uh
we found a uh uh
uh a passenger uh two seater from the
back of a van that was thrown away and
that's what i got to sleep on nice yeah
you make it work man i like that stuff
something about that it's not only is it
like romantic but it's actually awesome
because you're saving money for the
things you really find important in life
which is investing for your future
yeah
all right let's get this what we got
here kevin brady says
random fact about big mouth nick kroll
his father ran kroll industries who was
responsible for security of the twin
towers on 911. that sounds like
something that sounds true that's not
true though
that's crazy how about someone
fact-check that because that you know
corporate investigation risks risk
consulting cruel inc
huh american corporate investigations
and risk consultants i wrote a
fascinating book about that this is also
somebody you should try and get on if
you haven't i think was barry meyer
m-e-i-e-r who wrote a book about uh
corporate spying it had a lot to do with
russiagate and fusion gps but it was
about like general like these weird
corporate intelligence firms that are
like do all sorts of crazy really
screwed up stuff like they were the ones
who were like in working for harvey
weinstein investigating the one it was
fascinating fascinating books spiro
floropolis says i lost my job standing
up against woke and vaccine crap because
i wanted to do better for my daughter's
future it was worth it if tim cass needs
tech help i have 20 years experience
glad to hear it and we do
send an email uh let's say spin the ufo
yeah you check that enough let's put
your name on that
spiro fluoropolis
that might not be his real name no but
we'll uh we'll use use use the use that
in the subject and then we'll we'll take
a look because we we do need tech help
as we expand we have new buildings and
all that stuff so there you go
jordan james says two years ago at a
grocery would spend about 250 to 300 now
over 600 for the same amount of stuff
for a family of four
man
it's getting bad out there my friends
all right let's see oppressive straight
white male christian says
fairmont west virginia literally has
tim's man sandwich shop it's called
yan's hot dogs hot dog sauce mustard raw
onions the end
i love them simple you go in you get
food
i like it in and out it's very simple
right you go in and out you get a burger
you can have burger tube burger three
burger burger with stuff on it have an
ice cream in and out is amazing they
also got animal style highly recommend
if you haven't and run by conservatives
that's the thing people are hating on it
now because they're like it's a
california thing no they were run by
conservatives they were out opposed to
the vax mandate like i do extra crispy
in and out for the fries because
otherwise they just blanch them they hit
them once i think they do it twice for
you and get them nice and crispy see
everybody's always talking about what
you've got to ask for good old country
restaurant where you go in and they're
very nice to you and you can relax and i
don't want none of that i want to walk
in i want the server to walk up and say
what do you want i want a cheeseburger
bacon fries cider mayo
and a club soda done they leave they
come back out they give it to me no chit
chat no bs
you know i can't stand i can't stand
when i go in i already know what i want
to eat when i go to a restaurant before
we even go in for the most part going to
a diner yeah i'm going to get two eggs
bacon and sausage that's it question so
i sit down and the server walks up and
they're like um do you guys need menus
well yes obviously that people need
menus to know what they want to order me
i know what i want they'll say well i'm
just going to do the drinks first it's
like bro we are ready to order
can you just take our order no we need a
man restaurant where you go in and
they're like you just say eggs and bacon
done and they bring you eggs
are just grunt for the specific item on
the menu you want a breakfast place that
only serves two eggs two bacon two
sausage nothing else it's what you get
go home
are you gonna make people pay before or
after they eat
during
ooh i like it a surprise
surprise all right everybody if you have
not already smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends uh we're gonna have
that members only segment coming up at
11 p.m so you don't want to miss that
again at timcast.com uh you can follow
the show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me at timcast
will would you like to shout anything
out oh just my twitter right now
wheelchair at will chamberlain also uh
article three project is doing i think
it's a three project on twitter but look
it up i mean we're doing we've been done
doing great work opposing the katanji
brown jackson nomination
um
and
iap internet accountability project does
great work opposing the bad acts of big
tech so all three of those things cool
i'm seamus coughlin i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes you guys
should go check it out we're uploading a
cartoon tomorrow so go over there hit
subscribe hit the notification bell
watch it i love all of you thank you for
stopping by i love you guys too you're
great you're really great and to the
dude that has said you got four kids man
you're gonna raise great kids this is
thank you uh i also fasted yesterday for
24 hours maybe that was why my mood was
dipped today so i'm easing back into
eating life and i'll just think it's
great man yeah it was really really good
it was needed i overeat pizza so i did
it to myself it's my own punishment to
myself so that god doesn't punish me i
saw someone cooking at pizza at like
midnight
look no further
he was eating his sorrow he'd been
crying because we didn't get enough
likes
the giardano's i mean talk about hard to
resist but i just can't cheese myself
like that so not again giordano's is
like eating a brick of cheese yeah and
it expands slowly after you eat it like
a shot it takes a while to get drunk
same with the food takes a while to get
fat
no you're right it like it expands in
you it's true it's so good yeah that's
so good thanks everyone follow me ian
crossland.net if you wanna catch you
later why do we always end up talking
about food i end up leaving because
we're all hungry
i'm starving
does anybody want to go to waffle house
i'm going to away that's a good idea
after we record this members thing okay
let's do it for sure you guys can follow
me hold on real quick well you guys can
follow me on twitter at sarah patrick's
and on mines.com i also have sour patch
lids dot me we will see all of you over
at timcast.com for that member segment
or waffle house thanks for hanging out
we'll see you then bye guys
you